Musik
So Leute, da bin ich wieder.
Ich muss gerade nochmal alles anmachen.
Dauert kurz noch.
War blöd. Ich habe es heute Morgen wieder ausgeschaltet.
Ja, ich spiele Herr der Ringe online gerade wieder.
Exzellente Emotes.
Oh, ich bin gleich soweit.
Kann ich nochmal einen Vorschau-Rechner anmachen.
So, und jetzt?
Jetzt muss ich noch die Linux-Kiste anmachen, weil ich wieder alles...
Ich depp, ne?
Ich hab wieder alles ausgeschaltet, was es auszuschalten gibt.
A much desire to speak to him.
A Balrog of Morkoth.
F starten.
Moin.
So.
Es müsste eigentlich... Ah, okay.
Es ist an.
High IQ Passwort, kommt eh keiner drauf.
Das ist nicht 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Aber es ist auch nur 5 Zeichen lang.
Okay, so.
Dann muss ich erstmal etwas entspanntere Musik machen.
The Hobbits, The Hobbits, The Hobbits, The Hobbits.
Schon eine Weile nicht mehr
Excellent
So
Da sind wir
Kiste ist an
Zack
Terminal
Bam
Chaterino
Wenn man richtig schreibt, Chatterino, Bam, Firefox, Bam, alles da.
Achso, die Bahn, die Bahn sperrt mich immer noch aus.
Wie gesagt, wer es nicht mitbekommen hat, die Bahn sperrt gerne Linux-User aus.
Exzellent.
Hi, wie geht's dir?
Willst du die normale Antwort da drauf, die die alle sagen, oder willst du es wirklich wissen?
Weil die meisten Leute wollen nur so hören
Ja, ja, geht schon
Also ich kann euch sagen, wie es mir geht
Es hält sich in Grenzen
Ich hab die letzten paar
Letzten zwei Wochen
Wieder ein bisschen da mit meiner Problematik zu kämpfen
Immer mal wieder
Und das suckt, Alter
Massive
Suckt das
Die Bahn sperrt Linux-User aus, ja
Ne, das hast du gut erkannt
Ich klicke nicht so pralle.
Ich steigere mich auch in jeden Scheiß immer so rein.
Richtig dumm.
Obwohl ich weiß, das ist totaler Blödsinn.
Und dann mache ich mir Gedanken,
dass ich mich reinsteigern könnte.
Und dann steigere ich mich deswegen rein,
weil ich gedacht habe, ich könnte mich reinsteigern.
Das ist total wirr, Alter.
Ja Patrick, du hast ja mal geschrieben, du hast auch so Probleme in der Richtung.
Das ist richtig dumm, weil das...
Keine Ahnung.
Ich mache nachher ein bisschen Muskelentspannungsübungen.
Das hilft immer ganz gut.
Oh, wenn es gar nicht geht, kann ich ja noch eine zweite halbe Pille oder so nehmen.
Dann geht es wieder.
Egal.
Also.
Dann regt man sich auf, dass man sich aufhört.
Wer weiß, dass es sinnlos ist.
Ja.
Ja, vor allem ist es irgendwie so.
Ich denke mir dann so, ey, war jetzt schon eine Weile nichts mehr.
Was machst du denn, wenn es jetzt wieder anfängt?
Und dann hänge ich da im Kopf so dran.
Zuschauer, Leute.
Dann hänge ich da im Kopf so dran, dass es dann wieder anfängt.
Weil ich so lange darüber nachdenke,
was ist, wenn es wieder anfangen könnte.
Dass es wieder anfängt.
Total hängengeblieben.
Jetzt sind es 7-5 Zuschauer.
Ja, das
mache ich auch öfters mal.
Aber das geht.
Also es ist in letzter Zeit
wirklich besser.
Es ist eigentlich alles weg.
So gut wie.
Ja, immer mal ein bisschen durchhängen und so.
Es ist so gut wie alles weg.
Du schon wieder.
Warst du nicht schon vor zig Streams da und hast das gleiche?
Ich habe heute Senf tatsächlich zu mir genommen beim Mittagessen.
Es gab Nudel, Lachs und dabei so süßer Senf.
Exzellent.
Ja, aber was ich sagen wollte, also
es ist ja fast kaum noch was, ja.
Nudeln mit Lachs und Senf.
Süßer Senf, ja, passt ganz gut dazu.
Süßer Senf,
naja, eher auf den Lachs, nicht auf die Nudeln.
Aber das hat nicht schlecht geschmeckt.
Ja, das esse ich öfters.
Es gibt eigentlich zwei Sachen.
Entweder schmeiße ich da süßen Senf dabei
oder ich packe mir
ein paar Ladungen Eiwa
obendrauf. Das ist so Paprika.
Paprika, äh, ich weiß gar nicht was
Irgendwas aus Paprika
Naja, so, zumindest wie gesagt
Das, das mache ich gar nicht mehr so krass
Ähm, irgendwelche
Welt geht unter
Szenarien oder sowas oder ganz schlimm
Das einzige Problem, also
Ja, bis auf ein paar Durchhänge, ne
Das einzige Problem, was ich so die letzten Wochen eigentlich
Oder schon die ganze Zeit, aber vor allem die letzten Wochen
Noch übrig ist von der ganzen Geschichte ist
Dass ich mir immer Gedanken drüber mache
Was ist denn, wenn du jetzt wieder
was hättest, so. Und dann mache ich mir so
lange Gedanken drüber, bis ich dann was
habe. Richtig, richtig
dumm.
Ich weiß nicht, ich weiß nicht, ob das jemals besser
wird. Keine Ahnung.
Aber nachdem
alles andere...
Okay, okay. Ja.
Gut, gut, gut zu wissen.
Gut schon wissen. Ja, gut
zu wissen.
Das ist, das ist auch so,
Das ursprüngliche Problem ist bei mir auch so.
Das ursprüngliche Problem,
weshalb das alles angefangen hat,
habe ich eigentlich so gut wie gar nicht mehr.
Ich habe jetzt nur noch dieses
Was wäre, wenn?
Was wäre, wenn wieder was ist?
Und dann steigere ich mich so rein,
dass dann wieder was ist.
Das ist richtig dämlich, Alter.
Richtig hängen geblieben.
So.
Aber, Leute.
Heck, wait.
Oh, ich muss was trinken.
Warte mal.
Ja, komm, das klappt schon.
Es ist ja schon wieder auch besser.
Hast du denn vor, von den Medis runterzukommen?
Ja, aber ich hab's damit nicht eilig.
Das mach ich erst, wenn alles wieder gut ist.
Also ich hör jetzt nicht einfach auf, was zu nehmen,
weil das Zeug hilft ja.
Wenn aber wieder alles gut ist, dann,
keine Ahnung, in zwei, drei Jahren oder so,
dann gucke ich mal,
als man das absetzen kann.
Na gut, ich nehme das ja jetzt schon seit letztes Jahr im August.
Also das ist ja ziemlich Dauer aktuell.
Jaja.
Was ich nehme?
Äh.
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob ich es schon mal...
Ich will es jetzt auch nicht so sehr...
Ich sag dir, es geht nicht darum, dass ich es dir nicht erzählen will.
Ich will es jetzt nicht so ausbreiten.
Was ich nehme, ist das hier.
Also, ist nicht das Einzige, aber ist das Hauptsächliche dagegen.
Also, das, was jetzt damit...
Dass ich was nehme wegen ein bisschen zu hohem Blutdruck, das interessiert jetzt an der Stelle.
Was ich nehme, ist das hier.
Das da.
Das da nehme ich.
Es wird vorwiegend zur Behandlung...
Also Depressionen habe ich keine.
Panikstörungen habe ich auch nicht.
Ich habe das hier.
Angststörungen.
Aus den sinnlosesten Gründen ever.
Und über die eigentliche Sache mache ich mir, wie gesagt, gar keine Gedanken mehr.
Ja.
Nachher ist man immer schlauer.
Geht mir bei der Sache auch so.
Hätte ich das von Anfang an gewusst, also was es ausgelöst hat, will ich mich jetzt nicht so sehr drüber auslassen.
Aber die Vermutung, die der Chat hatte, es liegt an irgendwelchen Grills, das ist nicht das Problem gewesen.
Also, das wäre ja noch dümmer gewesen.
Aber, ähm, was es ausgelöst hat, weiß ich ja mittlerweile.
Das ist eigentlich das Dümmste aller Zeiten gewesen, sich da überhaupt so reinzusteigern.
Aber es ist halt so.
Kann man jetzt auch nichts mehr machen.
Hätte ich das vorher gewusst, hätte ich das damals nie gemacht.
Aber nachher wirst du ja schlauer.
Aber es ist jetzt halt so, wie es ist.
Kann man nichts machen.
Das nimmst du auch.
Da, guck an.
Das ist ja auch relativ verbreitet, das Zeug.
Man muss sagen, das macht jetzt natürlich nicht alles weg.
Von heute auf morgen.
Das sorgt aber dafür, dass es so im Durchschnitt besser ist.
Ich habe da noch ein paar Pillen für abends, die ich nehmen kann.
Oder darf ich auch noch zwei halbe am Tag nehmen, wenn ich will.
Das ist was anderes.
Das ist ein bisschen so zum Beruhigen.
Nein.
Ein bisschen zum Beruhigen, aber nichts, was abhängig macht.
Ein bisschen zum Beruhigen an Tagen, wo es mir halt besonders kacke geht.
Heute habe ich zum Beispiel vorhin eine halbe mal genommen.
Und es dauert immer drei Stunden oder so, bis es richtig wirkt.
Und dann passt es schon.
Kann ich heute Abend vielleicht noch eine halbe nehmen.
Mal schauen.
Tja, und dann war es ja so.
Okay, wenn wir jetzt schon mal im Thema sind, kann ich es gerade noch mal erzählen.
Also ich habe ja auch sogar eine Therapie gemacht.
letztes Jahr
bis quasi Ende letzten Jahres
und da ging es mir dann eigentlich ganz gut
und da habe ich dann auch
gesagt, das brauchen wir jetzt eigentlich nicht mehr, weil
der Scheiß ist halt teuer
das kostet halt richtig Kohle
so und
naja
da ging es mir gut
da habe ich gesagt, ey komm, wir lassen das
wir lassen das einfach mal
jetzt sein und ich hatte mich
in Frankfurt angemeldet
für einen
Aufenthalt in der Tagesklinik.
Da gehst du dann quasi von
ich glaube von
halb neun bis
weiß was ich, 16 Uhr oder so
gehst du da halt hin tagsüber
machst da Programm, ja
hast Gruppentherapie,
hast einzelne Gespräche,
hast nochmal, wird
nochmal wirklich ganz genau für dich
individuell geguckt wie es mit pillen aussieht und so dafür habe ich mich
angemeldet hat richtig lange wartezeiten gehabt ja also nur weil man privat
versichert das heißt noch lange nicht dass man in den termin kriegt richtig
lange wartezeiten gehabt und dann hatte ich so einen so einen
einführungsgespräch quasi mit denen irgendwann im februar oder oder ende
januar irgendwie sowas in dem dreh habe ich einstellen sie sofort dieses
Kennenlerngespräch mit denen gemacht.
Da haben die gesagt, ja, theoretisch
könnte man dann irgendwann Anfang Februar
auch loslegen. Habe ich gesagt, ja, super.
Aber aktuell geht es mir eigentlich so gut,
dass ich das gar nicht brauche.
Und da haben die gesagt, ja gut, dann
machen wir es doch so.
Dann melden sie sich wieder,
sollte es nochmal akut werden.
Und jetzt denke ich mir im Nachhinein auch,
vielleicht wäre es besser gewesen,
wenn ich da hingegangen wäre,
mal sechs Wochen am Stück wirklich
Programm gemacht hätte dagegen.
Aber auf der anderen Seite, wenn man da nicht voll, wenn man dann hingeht und gar keinen Bock drauf hat, ist ja auch nichts, ja.
Aber das ist immer noch eine Option, was ich machen könnte.
Zumindest unterm Strich kann ich sagen, versucht nicht allzu lange mit euch ganz alleine auszumachen bei Problemen.
Wir haben glücklicherweise viele Stellen, die einem helfen können.
So.
Genau, und jetzt gucken wir uns Stellenanzeigen an
Es sei denn, ihr wollt noch irgendwas dazu wissen
Aber, wie gesagt
Ich will kein
Da jetzt
großen Akt immer draus machen, ja
Es gibt auch Leute, das kenne ich von mir
Die haben
ähnliche Probleme
Und
Wenn dann im Stream oder öffentlich
darüber gesprochen wird und die hören
das, das
ähm, das regt die
total auf, ja.
Also das ist, das ist total
vielfältig. Also manche Leute, denen hilft das
richtig, wenn man, wenn man darüber redet.
Und manche Leute,
die haben auch die Probleme und die werden dann übelst nervös,
wenn das Thema aufkommt, ja.
Deswegen, man will's, man will's nicht.
Doch, die zahlen das beide.
Die zahlen das beide. Also das würde die,
ähm, das würde
die Krankenkasse bezahlen und das, das, also
im Prinzip ist egal, sagen wir,
Es bezahlt die Krankenversicherung, ist egal welche.
Das Ding ist nur, ich habe so einen Beitrag Rückerstattungstarif.
Und das ist so eine ganz weird-champige Regelung, die eigentlich geil ist, wenn man nichts hat.
Wenn man nichts hat, dann bekommt man, also wenn man nichts einreicht, ja.
Wenn man nichts einreicht, dann bekommt man die Hälfte des Beitrages für die Krankenversicherung zurückbezahlt.
Man muss aber dazu sagen, das klingt besser als es ist, weil die Krankenversicherung setzt sich ja zusammen aus dem eigentlichen Anteil für die Krankenversicherung, Risikozuschläge, Pflegeversicherung und Altersrückstellung.
Und diese Beitrag, diese 50% Beitragsrückerstattung, wenn man nichts einreicht für das Jahr, gelten nur für den Teil der Krankenversicherung davon.
Also es ist jetzt nicht Riesenbeträge oder so, die man da wieder bekommt, aber man bekommt ganz gut was wieder.
So, das Ding ist halt, wenn man dann was einreicht, dann gilt das für dieses Jahr nicht mehr mit der Beitragsrückerstattung und für das nächste Jahr auch nicht. Und wenn man zwei Jahre in Folge was einreicht, dann gilt das für das nächste und das übernächste Jahr auch nicht mit der Beitragsrückerstattung.
Rückerstattung. Das ist eigentlich geil, wenn man nix hat.
Weil man dann doch ganz gut
Kohle wiederkriegt. Zumindest ein bisschen Kohle wiederkriegt.
Aber wenn man was hat,
ist halt dumm.
Beziehungsweise wenn man was einreicht, ist halt
dumm, weil
dann kriegt man halt gar nix wieder.
So, und ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher.
Ich hatte das mal ausgerechnet,
ab wann sich das lohnt, was einzureichen.
Und ich hab jetzt erstmal gesagt,
ich reiche jetzt erstmal nix ein, weil
Ich will mir das jetzt nicht für die nächsten Jahre, wenn ich das dann auf die Reihe gekriegt habe, verbauen mit Beitragsrückerstattung.
Ja, das ist halt dumm.
Ist aber teuer. Ich konnte mir das durchaus leisten.
Also, falls es jemanden interessiert, eine Stunde Therapie kostet so 150, 160, 170, schwankt immer so ein bisschen Euro.
Eine Stunde sind 50 Minuten.
Eine Sitzung geht 50 Minuten.
Und vielleicht noch ein bisschen Vorbereitung, bla bla bla drumherum.
Also für eine Einheit Psychotherapie bezahlt man so 160 Euro.
Ja und ich habe das jetzt eine ganze Weile gemacht.
Jede Woche einmal.
Das geht schon ganz gut.
Und naja, ich habe das seit letztem Jahr...
Also ich habe das bestimmt ein halbes Jahr lang gemacht.
Das waren dann schon so
Sitzungen oder sowas.
Das kostet halt schon ein bisschen was.
mal
160.
60.
Hat halt einfach mal
6.400 Euro gekostet.
Das ist halt nicht ohne.
Das kostet halt.
Äh
Ne
Es gilt immer rückwirkend
Für den Zeitraum, wo die Leistung
Angefallen ist
Im Zweifelsfall, wenn die den Beitrag
Zurückerstattet haben, musst du dann mehr bezahlen
Und so, das ist, das haben die schon geschickt
Gemacht
Also es ist ganz schön, ganz schön teuer
Äh, achso, ich dachte, wenn man
Nichts hat, dann
Was?
ja du musst das immer selbst bezahlen aus seinem krankenhaus also das ist so
du kriegst von der jeweiligen praxis vom jeweiligen arzt von mir weil ein
therapeut kriegst du rechnung geschickt die bezahlst du dann und die kannst dann
beispielsweise über die app von einer krankenkasse da hochladen
Ja.
Ja, und bei mir setzt sich das halt dazu,
bei mir setzt sich das, also ich bezahle ungefähr 850,
wohlgemerkt, das ist das, was ich überweise,
das ist nicht das, was ich wirklich bezahle.
Also ich bezahle ungefähr 850 Euro im Monat
für die Krankenversicherung,
aber da ist, also,
da ist ja auch vom Arbeitgeber noch was dabei.
Aber überweisen muss ich das trotzdem.
Ich kriege dann weniger abgezogen.
Also da ist der Arbeitgeberanteil schon noch dabei.
Und bei mir setzt sich das halt zusammen.
Aus dem Krankenversicherungstarif.
Pflegeversicherung, die muss man abschließen.
Hast du keine Chance.
Und Altersrückstellung.
Genau, Altersrückstellung dabei.
Und was bei mir noch dabei kommt,
weil ich ja seit ein paar Jahren, wenn auch total wenig, weniger als überhaupt
minimal empfohlen wird, Blutdrucktabletten nehme. Ich nehme 4 Milligramm von meinen
Blutdrucktabletten und der Hersteller selbst sagt, unter 8 Milligramm
muss man eigentlich gar nicht anfangen. Und damit ist mein Blutdruck auch
vollkommen okay, aber die haben halt trotzdem gesagt, hoher Blutdruck, Ludel, 15%
Risikoaufschlag.
Kann man halt nichts machen.
Und dann komme ich so auf 850 Euro.
Die Hälfte davon ungefähr bezahlt
mein Arbeitgeber.
Also sagen wir mal so, ich bezahle so 450 Euro
oder irgendwie sowas in dem Dreh.
Das ist Pepo Burn Money.
In der gesetzlichen Krankenversicherung
bezahlst du noch mehr.
Ein bisschen.
Es ist bei mir jetzt kein allzu großer Unterschied, aber ein bisschen.
Ja, ja.
Die machen keine Faxen.
Nee, nee.
Hm.
Ja.
Ich habe auch
GKV maximal
Dings bezahlt
Jeder der sich privat versichern darf
Bezahlt maximal
Also wie gesagt
Es ist ein bisschen mehr
Ich glaube man bezahlt
Maximal bezahlt man
Gesetzliche Versicherung
ähm, ich glaub
1000, 1000
80 Euro oder irgendwie
sowas ist es mittlerweile, ich weiß nicht, ist sau teuer
das ist und
und man kriegt teilweise
dafür nicht mal Termine
naja, das ist teuer
ne, ne, ne, ich bin seit
Dezember
24, glaube ich.
Privatversichert.
Wieso kostet das in Deutschland mehr als in der Schweiz?
Keine Ahnung, weil bei uns so ziemlich
alles beschissen ist in der Richtung, Alter.
Klingt mich ja auf immer.
Ja.
Naja, ist auch egal.
Ich weiß auch nicht, ob ich das wirklich...
Ob ich das noch lange mache.
Weil ich plane...
Lohnt sich das?
Naja, du musst halt gucken, dass du genug Geld auf der hohen Kante hast.
Also, dass du ein bisschen vorsorgst, was das angeht.
Also, es ist ja erstmal so.
Wenn du dann in Rente gehst, dann fällt da Teil für die Pflegeversicherung weg und das, was du für die Altersrückstellung zurückgelegt hast, kommt zum Tragen.
Das heißt, du bezahlst dann auf einen Schlag deutlich weniger, sobald du in Rente gehst, aber ab da bleiben halt alle Beitragserhöhungen und so komplett an dir hängen.
Also wenn du da nicht vorgesorgt hast, ist schlecht.
Aber dafür habe ich ja meinen ETF.
Und wie gesagt, ob ich das lange mache, bin ich mir ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so sicher.
Weil dadurch, dass mir das nicht so gut geht, ich bin gerade am überlegen,
ob ich nicht auf
ähm
also wir haben, ich muss das
erzählen, bei uns auf der Arbeit fällt eine ganze
Ecke Rufbereitschaft weg
und ähm
dadurch, dass es mir gerade nicht so gut geht, bin ich gerade
auch am überlegen, ob ich auf 65%
reduzieren sollte
und dann bin ich unter der Grenze,
wo man sich privat versichern kann.
Dann müsste ich mich wieder gesetzlich...
Was auch immer.
Leute, lassen wir das Thema sein.
Regt mich nur auf, wenn ich mir darüber Gedanken mache.
Tazi TV, schön, dass du am Start bist.
Wie geht's den Stons?
Den geht es relativ gut. Ich habe mein Handy nicht hier.
Das war die Antwort auf die Frage, wie geht es dir?
Genau, die hat jetzt 20 Minuten, 25 Minuten.
Zumindest eine Sache, was ich auf jeden Fall machen werde.
Also sollte ich das so machen, mich wieder gesetzlich zu versichern,
Ich werde auf jeden Fall eine Anwartschaft machen, dass ich, wenn mal wirklich was sein sollte, zurück kann, ohne Gesundheitsprüfung in die private Krankenversicherung.
Und ich werde meine Krankenversicherung umwandeln in eine Zusatzversicherung fürs Krankenhaus.
So mit Einbettzimmer und allem Zeug.
Das werde ich, sollte ich das wieder machen, das mache ich auf jeden Fall.
Man weiß ja, es ist immer gut in Deutschland, man weiß nie, was die nächsten Jahre kommt,
Optionen offen zu haben, was man machen kann in der Richtung.
So.
Genau.
Ja, da habe ich mich jetzt lange noch drüber ausgelassen. Ich will jetzt nicht wieder anfangen.
Ich...
Das reicht jetzt
Was?
Ach, Krankenhaus
Ach so
Also Chat, Chat, Chat
Wenn ich es mir aussuchen könnte
Ja
Also mal angenommen es gäbe die Auswahl
Bei einer Zusatzversicherung fürs Krankenhaus
Zwischen Chefarztbehandlung
Und eigenem Glasfaseranschluss
Im Krankenhaus
Dreimal dürft ihr raten was ich nehmen würde
Was juckt mich der Chefarzt
Alter
Eigener Glasfaseranschluss, das wär's.
Das würde ich sofort machen.
So instant.
Eigener Glasfaseranschluss.
Chat, wie sieht's bei euch aus?
Wenn ihr die Auswahl hättet,
Chefarztbehandlung oder eigener Glasfaseranschluss
im Krankenhaus?
Was würdet ihr machen?
Ich bin eh der Meinung,
Chefarztbehandlung ist komplett overrated,
she baited.
Ohne Chefarzt bist du auch länger da.
Das würde ich so nicht sagen.
Richtig, richtig.
Genau das denke ich mir nämlich auch.
So, jetzt aber Stellenanzeigen, Leute.
Also, habt ihr irgendwas, was wir uns angucken sollen?
Ansonsten gucken wir mal bei den üblichen Verdächtigen.
Wollen wir hier Jobs?
Jetzt wird's schlimm.
Jetzt wird's ganz schlimm, Leute.
LinkedIn.
Oh ne, da muss man sich ja einloggen.
Fuck.
Wie, da muss man sich...
Was soll denn das? Warum muss man sich da einloggen?
Ich hab doch mein Account hier nicht mehr.
WTF, Leute.
Okay, wir machen uns jetzt ein Fake-Account.
Mal gucken, ob das funzt.
Zeit für Peter Aguilé 2.0.
Mal gucken, ob man sich da nicht mit Telefon bestätigen muss oder so.
Moment, Moment.
Wir probieren mal was aus, okay?
Gmail, wir registern uns jetzt.
Wir registern uns jetzt.
Create an account for personal use.
First Name.
Nein.
Pifehead.
Engineer.
Äh.
Custom.
Ähm.
Pepe, please.
I use Arch, by the way.
Please refer to me as other.
So, März, keine Ahnung, 1. März 1900.
Ich bin alt.
Next.
Head Engineer 27.
Nee.
Nee, ähm
5, ach
Nee, nee, nee
Der Zahl vorne darf man gar nicht, oder?
Der Zahl vorne, geht der Zahl vorne
Bei E-Mail-Adressen?
Moment, this username is already taken
Alter
Okay, HeadEngineer27
Ganz toll
Passwort, okay, dann denke ich mir jetzt mal was aus
Chat
Ähm
Moment, Moment, Moment
Ich muss mir das Passwort aufschreiben
Sonst wird das nix
Okay, perfekt
Ähm
Oh, ich hab mich verschrieben, geht schon gut los
Okay
Perfekt
Next
Nein
Man muss jetzt
Man muss jetzt eine Telefonnummer angeben
Nein
F
Das geht jetzt nicht
Muss man seit Jahren
Naja siehste mal
Wie lange ich da schon keinen...
Ja, ne, ich will doch hier weiter mit Google einloggen machen.
Es gibt doch einmal Nummern.
Neuberlinkt in Mitglied werden.
Diese Scheißseite, Alter
Okay
Das geht bestimmt nicht, oder?
Das geht bestimmt nicht, 10-Minute-Mail
Das haben die bestimmt geblockt
Ich will das nicht
Ich will das nicht anzeigen
Ähm.
Oh, Listening, Leute.
Bester Soundtrack.
Düdüdüdüdüdüdüdü.
Five Head Engineer.
Sicherheitsprüfung.
Nein, nein, ich bin echt.
Was?
Link in.
Scheiß Seite, Alter.
Select bicycles.
Okay.
Das ist kein
Bicycle, aber muss man das anklicken?
Bicycle, Bicycle.
Bicycle.
Verify.
Bus.
Bus, Bus, Bus.
Okay.
F.
Diese Scheiße, Alter, Mann.
Okay, ich schalte mal.
Oh, nee.
Was ist das?
Okay, whatever
Nochmal
Was?
Oh Gott, diese Seite ist so scheiße.
Okay, nicht LinkedIn, Leute.
Wir gucken nicht auf LinkedIn.
Das ist einfach nicht zum Aushalten.
Wir gucken lieber hier.
Und dann gebe ich das Wallet auf.
Ist schon schlimm, oder?
Was es für ein Akt ist, sich bei so einer Kack-Seite zu registrieren.
Mach mich auch.
Mich auch.
Ja, das ist wie bei Microsoft.
Hilfe uns den Kampf
gegen die Roboter zu gewinnen.
Oder irgendwie sowas.
Hilfe uns die Roboter zu schlagen.
Genau.
Okay, ich hab noch eine Idee.
Eine Idee hab ich noch.
Eine Idee habe ich noch
Äh
Chat, warum geht das in einem anonymen Tab?
Warum geht das da?
Warum muss ich mich da jetzt nicht einloggen?
Hä?
Easy, Hacker-Man.
Okay, also.
Dann suchen wir doch mal
Standort Frankfurt
an der Oder.
Berufserfahrung und Berufserfahren
Management. MonkaS, Alter.
Und dann kann man da auch
sowas sagen, wie
Art der Beschäftigung.
Ne.
Remote.
Ich würde gerne sowas wie
im IT-Bereich
anklicken. Gibt sowas nicht?
Stellen oder Unternehmen?
Ja gut, da könnte ich sowas eingeben.
Gucken wir mal nach Linux. Okay. Linux.
Ach so kann man da.
Da kann man einfach nur Linux eingeben.
Leute, so sieht es aus.
Please allow me to interject for a moment.
Es ist GNU plus Linux.
Also, so.
Was gibt es denn hier Schönes?
Achso, danach gucken wir uns das vom RF-Programmer an.
Full-Stack-Entwickler.
Lasst mal hier schauen.
Also, wir gucken jetzt erst einmal schnell drüber, bis wir irgendwas finden, was wir uns ein bisschen im Detail angucken wollen.
Warum ist eigentlich, by the way, Berufserfahrung wieder weg? Berufserfahren?
First Level Support. MonkaW, Alter. First Level Support IT. Mind Systems GmbH.
Das wird schlimm. Bin ich für den Job geeignet? Okay, ah, da muss man sich einloggen. Gut.
warum ist das eigentlich so schlecht lesbar auf der Webseite?
Warum ist die so reudig?
Warum ist die so kacke, die Webseite?
Das ist doch was für uns, Leute.
First Level Support IT.
Kundenanfragen.
Oh, ich kann mir nichts besseres vorstellen.
leute helpdesk für microsoft 365 ein traum
klientenadministration von windows workstation perfekt leute perfekt
betreuung weiterer produktgruppen das ist wildcard regax sternchen punkt
Sternchen. Regex.
Ist das hier... Ach du Scheiße, Alter.
Da hätte ich ja mal gar keinen Bock drauf.
Warum schreiben das eigentlich so viele?
Tägliche Erinnerung, dass LinkedIn
zu Microsoft gehört. Ach, stimmt.
Das habe ich schon wieder vergessen.
Flache Hierarchien und kurze Entscheidungswege
Warum schreiben das eigentlich immer so viele?
Ist mir doch
Egal, Hauptsache der Laden läuft
Okay, dann lassen wir irgendwas suchen
Linux Administrator
Guck mal, das ist mal was, wozu ich was sagen kann
Wenn ihr irgendwas habt, Leute
Was wir uns angucken sollen zusammen
Schreibt es in den Chat
Und sollte ich es übersehen, erinnert mich ruhig nochmal dran
Irgendwie ist der Chat gerade der Meinung
Keine Ahnung, warum das Kommentar eben von SunSlayer geblockt war
Keine Ahnung, was da Twitch wieder sich gedacht hat
Okay, schauen wir mal
Linux-Administrator bei Grafitas.
Die kenne ich. Der Name sagt mir irgendwas.
Ist das irgendein Personalvermittlungs-Zeitarbeitsding oder sowas?
Irgendwie kommt mir der Name bekannt vor.
Okay, erstmal passenden Raketen-Emojis am Start.
Okay, Betrieb, Weiterentwicklung, Optimierung, Linux, Administration, Komplex, also ja gut, Standardzeug.
Sicherstellung von Stabilität, Performance und Sicherheit der Systeme, Analyse und Behinderung von Second- und Third-Level-Support,
Automatisierung von Prozessen und wie kontinuierliche Verbesserung bestehender Strukturen.
Mitarbeiter an spannenden Infrastruktur- und Cloud-Projekten.
Ziemliche Standardstellenanzeige.
Fundierte Erfahrung in der Administration von Linux-Systemen.
Das wäre für einen Linux-Administrator nicht verkehrt, ja.
Das sieht mit den Emojis und diesen Punkten, sieht für mich auch ein bisschen nach KI aus, oder?
Findet ihr nicht auch, dass es ein bisschen KI-generiert aussieht?
Oder zumindest der KI Stichpunkte hingeschmissen und gesagt, mach mir mal eine Stellenanzeige draus.
Das ist doch, ja das ist doch KI.
Linux-Administrate bei SimBio.
Moment, Darmstadt? Hab ich nicht gesagt Frankfurt?
com people da kannte ich mal leute die da gearbeitet haben das war wohl vor
frag mich nicht zehn jahren oder so gar nicht so übel die machen java basierte
software und so was wenn ich das noch nicht im kopf habe so also was haben wir
hier linux administrator
Also wenn das immer so richtig
lange Dinger sind mit Bullet Points,
aber es sind keine Emojis,
vielleicht nicht GPT.
Du hast einen Freund von mir dahin vermittelt
vor vier Jahren oder so.
Stimmt.
okay was wollen die hier administration muss gehen
administration weiterentwickeln der linux serverlandschaft ok gewährleistung eines
stabilen sicheren datenschutzkonform okay betreuung aus bei der container plattform
doch kuba net ist ok analyse dokumentation die machen hier wieder den fehler die sind
der meinung analyse und dokumentation ist wichtig viel wichtiger ist keine fehler
zu machen dass alles first try funktioniert dann braucht man keine
dokumentation keine kommentare keine analyse es gibt keine ausfallzeiten man
braucht keinen support nix braucht man einfach first try immer ohne fehler
alles machen. Error-free Programming. Genau, einfach make no mistakes, think extra hard
dabei schreibt also administration und weiterentwicklung von active directory
sowie entra die wie kommen wir auf die idee dass es eine gute idee ist ihren
linux admin mit der administration von active directory die zu beauftragen
Das verstehe ich nicht, Leute.
Verantwortung für den Netzwerkbetrieb.
Ach, das auch noch?
Okay, so langsam wird es ja interessant hier.
Also, sie suchen einen Linux-Admin,
der sich allerdings auch anscheinend ganz gut mit Windows-Kram in Azure auskennt
und nebenbei noch richtig high IQ ist, was Netzwerk angeht.
Das sind schon mal drei Stellen in einem
Planung und eigenständige
Das wird ja immer noch besser
Planung und eigenständige Umsetzung von IT-Projekten
Projektmanager bist du auch noch
Sind schon mal vier Jobs in einem
Standardisierung und Automatisierung von IT-Prozessen
Das ist streng genommen auch ein eigener Job
Wobei man halt sagen muss
automatisierung von IT-Prozessen passt da schon dazu. Also es ist jetzt nicht
ganz abwegig, dass das da dabei steht. Aber im großen Stil ist
das auch ein eigener Stopp. Steuerung und Koordination externer Dienstleister.
Zum Teil ja, aber du solltest da nie alleine den Hut für aufhaben als
Admin. Unterstützung bei der Weiterentwicklung der Rechenzentrums- und
Netzwerkinfrastruktur. Wie darf man sich das vorstellen? Wollen die damit sagen, Unterstützung
bei der Weiterentwicklung, also Server im fünften und sechsten Stock tragen? Das würde
ich sagen, das passt schon zu einem Linux-Admin. Habe ich früher ja auch gemacht. Ansprechpartner
für interne Anwendungen bei technischen Fragestellungen. Ansprechpartner für interne Anwendungen?
Der Linux-Admin?
Äh.
Warum?
Also der stellt vielleicht den Server bereit und installiert dann einen Java drauf.
Aber Kenner der Anwendung?
Achso.
Ne, die meinen damit bei Technik.
Die meinen damit sowas wie Java-Anwendung kackt ab.
Weil?
und dann guckt man nach und stellt fest,
ah, weil
irgendwie die Limits erreicht wurden.
Okay, dann macht es Sinn.
Sorgfältige Dokumentation sowie Sicherstellung des Wissenstransfers.
Gibt es eigentlich irgendeinen Laden, wo das wirklich funktioniert?
Die meinen, Anwender ruft Anwalt Drucker kaputt.
Also wenn die das wirklich meinen, dann passt es nicht dazu.
Okay, aber haben wir doch schon mal hier,
das ist ein Job, das gehört dazu.
Das gehört auch noch dazu.
Das ist meinetwegen auch noch dazu.
Zweiter Job.
Vierter Job.
Vier und ein halb der Job.
Okay, vier und ein halb Jobs in einem.
Top.
Sekunde, Chatgear.
kamotori schreibt ich habe sich wirklich was mit als hin zu suchen suche aber derzeit auch
einen job um du siehst dich auch aktuell nach einem job um okay meine güte neun von zehn
stellen die man dann mal findet ist irgendwie so ein zeitarbeitsvermögen das sieht man hier
auch oft mal ganz davon abgesehen dass teilweise wochen komplett vorgehen und neue schau stelle
Überall an Stellen macht es trotzdem...
Ja, äh, Stellen ist...
aktuell ziemlich beschissen.
Gerade als Einsteiger muss es nochmal extra mehr beschissen sein.
Können wir gleich gucken.
Ich würde gerade nochmal den hier fertig schauen.
Also das sind viereinhalb Jobs in einem schon mal.
Das ist doch schon mal was, oder?
So, was sollste wissen?
Fundierte Kenntnisse in der Administration moderner IT-Infrastrukturen.
Insbesondere Virtualisierung, vor allem ja.
Linux, idealerweise Red Hat.
Web-Server, einfach random.
Microsoft 365 Entra-ID.
Ja, was jetzt, Leute? Wollt ihr einen Linux-Admin?
Die Kombination gibt es äußerst selten, dass Linux-Admins Bock auf Microsoft 365 und enten sich mit Entra-ID auskennen.
Das kommt jetzt nicht so oft vor.
Ach, Datenbank machst du auch noch.
Wie Postgres?
MSSQL?
Idealerweise auch Informix.
Hat das mal irgendjemand gehört?
Carsten.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Carsten, du bist nicht zufällig mal ein Bekannter aus Dresden, oder?
Exposed.
Ne, ne.
Ja, das dachte ich mir.
Der heißt auf Twitch, glaube ich, auch irgendwie CarstWords oder so.
Okay, was ist Infomix?
Gibt es leider im VoIP-Umfeld relativ häufig. Aha.
Also ich bin dann heilfroh. Bisher wollte von mir noch nie einer irgendwas mit Entra-ID haben und ich habe davon auch keine Ahnung.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich will mit Active Directory auch gar keine Ahnung haben.
Ich mache einen ganz großen Bogen, was Administration von Microsoft-Sachen angeht.
Okay.
Informix ist der Produktname von...
Für ein Datenbank-Management-System...
wurde 2001 von IBM...
übernommen...
bis 2000...
Oh, das ist irgend so ein richtig krasses Legacy-Ding, oder?
Im April 2017 IBM die Entwicklung und den Fachspezifischen Subordnungen an das indische Unternehmen HCL...
Moment, HCL?
HCL, HCL, das kommt mir irgendwie bekannt vor.
HCL...
Ist das nicht die Terraform?
Ist HCL nicht das Format, das Terraform-Format?
Aber das hat damit wahrscheinlich nichts zu tun.
Okay, das ist
irgendwelches super krasses Legacy-Zeug.
Das siehst du allein schon daran, dass es
da irgendwas, irgendein Kram für Solaris
für gibt.
Hindu, Moment.
Hindu Computers Limited.
Ah ja.
Die, die, oh, die Lotus Notes
haben die auch am Start, na dann
Okay, das ist
irgendein super krasses Legacy Zeug
Informix
Kenntnis ITIL basierter
Service Prozesse und Changement
Leute, das ist
da wird sich endlich mal mein
ITIL Kurs
bezahlt machen
Das Landratsamt bei dir hat Lotus Notes.
Ich glaube, ganz viele haben noch so Legacy-Notes-Installationen.
Erfahrung mit Netzwerkadministration und Active Directory.
Ausgeprägt.
Okay, also sind wir uns einig.
Wir runden auf auf fünf Jobs in einem.
Weil hier kommt ja jetzt auch noch Datenbank und...
...Informix und Zeug...
...debei.
Deswegen.
fünf jobs in einem familiäres arbeitsumfeld flache hierarchien und
kurze entscheidungswege wie gesagt wen juckt eigentlich so lange solange der
laden läuft
da hast du recht das meiste davon ist nicht linux admin
was haben sie denn sonst noch zu sagen?
okay bla bla bla bla
bla bla bla bla
37,5 Stunden Woche
flexible Arbeitszeiten
und mobiles Arbeiten
die sagen aber nicht genau was
ja das heißt die schreiben das wahrscheinlich nur rein
damit sie es gut liest
okay
Okay
Ja, okay
Ähm
Jobrat finde ich überhaupt nicht so dolle
Kinderkrankheit, okay
Gemeinsame Events
wie Betriebsausflug und Weihnachtsfeier
Yeah
Modern und bei Freiburg
Ja
Ziemlich nur nach 15 Stellen Anzeige
Ähm
Was ich ein bisschen fragwürdig finde ist
Dass da Linux Admin steht
Und
What the fuck
Was hab ich denn jetzt gedrückt
Was hab ich denn jetzt überhaupt
Kann man da draufklicken
Ne
Ach man kann da oben draufklicken
Dann geht es als eigene Seite auf
Da muss man ja erstmal draufkommen
Das ist aber auch nicht zu erkennen, oder?
Na gut.
Also, ein bisschen problematisch ist,
dass es letztendlich viereinhalb Jobs in einem sind
und vieles davon überhaupt nichts mit Deluxe zu tun hat.
Naja, also das ist nicht so geil.
Dann gucken wir mal, was ihr geschickt habt.
Wir fangen mal an mit...
Und was fangen wir an? Wir sagen von links nach rechts.
Fullstack-Entwickler.
Männlich-Weiß-Deutsch mal wieder.
Codewerk steht für Technikbegeisterung.
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Die hatten wir doch schon mal hier im Stream, oder?
Und die fand ich doch das letzte Mal auch gar nicht so schlecht.
Ich bilde mir ein, ich fand das
Ich fand das gar nicht so, gar nicht so übel
Das letzte Mal
Leute, falls ich irgendwas übersehen habe
Müsst ihr es nochmal, müsst ihr es nochmal posten
Ne, ich hab nichts übersehen
So, also lasst uns mal gucken
Vollzeit in Berlin, Cottbus, Karlsruhe, Murnau.
Murnau am Staffelsee.
Das sieht nett aus da.
In Oberbayern.
Exzellent.
Okay, schauen wir mal.
Was?
Wie steht ihr eigentlich zu
IT-Jobs in nicht-IT-Unternehmen?
So ist das Problem.
Also zum Beispiel
Helpdesk-Kram in Industrie... Also,
mal ganz davon abgesehen, ich finde Helpdesk
generell kacke.
Egal, ob in IT oder nicht-IT-Unternehmen.
Ist das dann besonders
nervig, so viele Menschen um einen herum, die
keinen PC... Oder... Ne, ne, ne.
Ich glaube, Helpdesk ist das Problem.
helpdesk ist immer nervig egal wo helpdesk ist immer kacke ansonsten auch in nicht-it-unternehmen
braucht es heutzutage also insofern bin ich das als it job in nicht-it-unternehmen
ist eigentlich kein Problem.
Du liebst deinen Helpdesk-Job?
Ey, es gibt Leute, die haben da Spaß dran.
Bin ich froh, weil dann muss ich das nicht machen.
Wenn es da genug Leute gibt, die das immer machen wollen.
Das ist schon okay.
Macht ihr das nur.
Das soll ja letztendlich jeder machen, was er Spaß macht.
Nur weil für mich Helpdesk das Schlimmste aller Zeiten ist, kann das euch ja trotzdem Spaß machen.
99% sind wie
Färbig Excel diese Zeilen um
Tja
Da würde ich Zustände beikriegen
Aber generell
Endkundensupport
in welcher Art auch immer ist.
Übelster Abfall.
Ich hatte bei der alten Arbeit manchmal
das Problem, dass bei mir Endkunden angerufen haben.
Aus Versehen.
Die wollten gar nicht bei mir
rauskommen. Ich hatte eine Durchwahl,
die war
ähnlich
zur Durchwahl
von irgendeiner
Abrechnungsstelle.
Und ihr könnt euch ja vorstellen,
wenn Leute anrufen,
wegen der Abrechnung sind sie eh schon immer
pisst.
Und da haben die aus Versehen bei mir angerufen
und wollten irgendwas wissen wegen Abrechnung.
Da musste ich dann immer die erstmal bremsen.
Die haben dann direkt so so, ja, ja, ja, wir planen
meine Abrechnung. Oh, langsam, stopp,
stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, langsam, stopp.
Also, ja, ganz ruhig, aber sie sind
komplett falsch.
Das Produkt, das wir
täglich nutzen, genau solche Leute sind
da am Start.
Das Produkt, mit dem wir täglich arbeiten.
Ja.
Da hatte sich mal
eine E-Mail
oder ich weiß gar nicht, ob es eine E-Mail oder ein Anruf war.
Zumindest kam
über Umwegen
bei mir jemand raus
von, ich glaube,
irgendeinem Krankenhaus oder so
ganz wirres Zeug,
wo ich sofort wusste, dafür bin ich
definitiv nicht zuständig.
Und hat irgendwas
erzählt von, das System geht nicht.
Und dann habe ich halt
zurückgeschrieben und gesagt, also sie sind hier ganz
falsch.
Aber vielleicht
finden wir ja irgendeinen, der sich damit auskennt.
Um welches System geht
es denn? Und dann war die Antwort,
das System, mit dem wir
täglich arbeiten. Mit
20 Ausrufezeichen oder so
dahinter.
Da habe ich mir auch gedacht, okay, weißt du was, ich reagiere einfach nicht weiter drauf.
Ist mir zu doof.
Es ist auf jeden Fall definitiv nichts von uns.
Okay, aber jetzt lesen wir das erstmal durch.
Also, in Berlin, Cottbus, Karlsruhe, Murnau.
Codefax steht für Technik, Begeisterung, Innovation und Zuverlässigkeit mit flachen Achtes.
Wir haben heute ja bisher nur flache Hierarchien gehabt.
Freiraum und Entwicklungsmöglichkeiten, ob in Zügen oder Industrieanlagen.
Wir bringen dieses Thema von morgen dazu, miteinander zu reden.
Aha, als Fullstack-Entwickler.
Deine Aufgaben.
Du bringst dein Wissen an unsere Projekte ein und bist zusammen mit dem Team verantwortlich für...
Okay.
Du verantwortest die Konzeption, Weiterentwicklung und Wartung von Anwendungen in Frontend und Backend.
Dabei gestaltest du die Modellierung, den Aufbau sowie die Implementierung von Datenbanksystemen.
Ja, okay.
Du wirkst bei Design, Konzepterstellung und Entwicklung von User.
Okay, die meinen das mit Fullstack, aber ernst, ne?
Du machst Frontendentwicklung, Design, Datenbank.
Du testest deine Software und führst die Behebung von welche Fehler?
Das ist doch schon mal das falsche Grindset-Mindset.
Das High-Performer-Mindset ist doch, keine Fehler zu machen.
Wie gesagt, dann braucht man keine Kommentare, keine Dokumentation, keine Tests.
Das ist einfach viel effizienter.
Keine Fehler machen.
Ja.
Ja, da muss ich dir recht geben.
Ich kenne auch keinen, der das alles kann, plus ganz gut ist in Design.
Guckt euch mal an.
Also ich würde jetzt mal von mir behaupten, ich kriege ganz brauchbar Frontend und Backend hin.
Und ich kenne mich auch mit dem Betrieb dann von Anwendungen aus.
Datenbanksystem müsste man mal gucken.
Also ich sage mal so, einen größten Teil davon könnte ich schon machen.
Und ihr kennt meine HTML Design oder CSS Design Skills.
Das sieht ja mittlerweile ganz brauchbar aus, oftmals, was ich fabriziere, aber es ist weit davon entwernt, wirklich gut auszusehen.
Wir bauen auf dein Wissen und du gibst dein Know-how an unsere Junior-Entwickler weiter.
Okay, so was sie jetzt genau machen und verwenden.
Okay, Ausbildung Fullstack.
Du bist ein Fullstack-Development-Allrounder.
Ach, jetzt kommen wir zu...
Okay.
Programmiersprache Node.js
Streng genommen ist Node.js
keine Programmiersprache, aber wir wollen
jetzt mal nicht pipslicher sein als der Papst
C Sharp
Python
und
Placing the Fast Written in Rust
Das finde ich cool
Das ist eine interessante Kombination
JavaScript
C Sharp
Python und Rust
Das ist eine gute Kombination
Kennt ja niemand, der JavaScript, Python, Rust und C Sharp kann
Doch, du kennst mich
Okay, Python bin ich jetzt nicht der große Checker, das stimmt
Also JavaScript kriege ich ganz gut hin
C Sharp kriege ich ziemlich gut hin
Rust
Okay
Python, naja
Ich würde auch sagen, ich kann
JavaScript und C Sharp
Also damit kannst du mich was machen lassen
Bei den anderen zwei Sachen
Brauchen wir eine etwas
Erweiterte Einarbeitungsphase, ja
Ertappt, ja
Du hast bereits mit Frameworks und Technologien wie Angular React NestJS.
Was meint NestJS?
Ist das, ist das, ist das, ähm, ich kenne NextJS.
Was ist denn NestJS schon wieder?
Leute, es hört denn auf bei JavaScript.
Das hat nichts mit NextJS zu tun, oder?
Next und Next.js
ist nicht das gleiche, oder?
Oh, warte mal.
Next.js versus Next.js.
Äh.
Okay, was auch immer.
Angular React
Next.js ASP.NET
Da muss ich wieder den
ähm
Actually, ich weiß es besser raushängen lassen, weil korrekterweise müsste es ASP.NET Core heißen.
Es sei denn, wir reden von .NET Framework 4.8 Anwendungen, die noch in ASP.NET sind, was ich aber mal nicht hoffen will für die.
Aber es ist klar, was gemeint ist.
sowie Datenbroker und relationalen
und objektorientierten Datenbanken.
Du bist sicher im Umgang
mit Infrastrukturen wie
Docker, Kubernetes,
okay, okay, okay.
Die meinen das mit Fullstack hier aber wirklich
ernst, oder?
Also das, da muss ich jetzt, das ist
vielleicht echt dann schon ein bisschen viel des Guten,
oder?
Docker, Kubernetes oder Ansible sowie Protokoll? Hä? HTTP, GIP, IPC, TLS, MQTT, AMQT? Heißt das nicht AMQP? Heißt das nicht AMQ... Das heißt AMQP! Sag ich doch! Keckel.
Beinhaltet Fullstack auch DevOps? Bei denen nötigst du wahrscheinlich schon, wenn ich mir das hier so angucke.
Du bringst erste Erfahrung mit Requirement Engineering mit.
Du hast idealerweise bereits mit Tools wie Figma gearbeitet und interessierst dich für ihr IOX.
Für dich steht die Entwicklung innovativer und effizienter Softwarelösungen im Fokus.
Dazu nutzt du gängig Tools wie Copilot.
Okay. Microsoft 365, äh, Copilot, Agent, HDXX, Quickscope.
Also das ist Fullstack ja in allen Ehren, Leute.
Aber das ist dann doch schon ein bisschen zu viel des Guten, meiner Meinung nach.
es ist Datenbank, es ist Frontend
es ist Frontend Design
es ist Backend
mit mehreren Backend Technologien
ähm
Containerisierung
vielleicht Betrieb von Kubernetes
äh Server Automatisierung
mit Ansible
also das ist dann
auch schon ein bisschen viel des Guten.
Also da muss ich ehrlich sagen,
das ist zu viel in einem.
Und wenn der Schwerpunkt
und wenn der Schwerpunkt
eben auf, was weiß ich,
diesen zwei Sachen hier liegt, sagen wir mal
Schwerpunkt,
Node.js oder C-Sharp Backend
und Frontend Angular, dann sollte man das
irgendwie auch hervorheben, weil
ansonsten ist das
wirklich so eine halbe
ein ganzes Team
in einer Person.
Find ich jetzt irgendwie nicht so doll.
Was ist Requirements Engineering?
Das weiß ich,
kann ich aber nicht erklären.
Also irgendwas mit Anforderungen.
So.
Was macht ein
Was macht ein Requirements Engineer?
Der fährt durch Tunnel.
Chioso Käse, moin.
Mit dem Kunden schauen, was es wirklich braucht und danach genaue Anforderungen für die Entwickler definieren.
Der Chat, ich muss das gar nicht lesen.
Der Chat ist einfach schon wieder so high IQ, dass die Erklärung schneller ist als googeln.
Chat, ich muss mal was nachgucken.
Ich hab bestimmt wieder Subscriptions vorhin übersehen.
Ich bin da immer
schlimm drin, was das angeht.
Carsten,
danke schön für den Sub.
Wenn es euch übrigens
gefällt, könnt ihr mir an der Stelle auch ein Follow dalassen.
Freut mich auch.
Sirius Max, Pog Subscription,
Splixer wieder am Start.
Okay, sonst hab ich nix.
Overlooked.
Zack.
Next.
Cloud Operations Engineer.
Ach so, habe ich euch eigentlich schon erzählt,
dass ich
einen neuen Jobtitel auf der Arbeit habe.
Philwo,
danke schön für den Sub.
Huge Subscription.
Ich bin jetzt nicht mehr Linux Engineer.
Ich bin jetzt...
Habe ich euch erzählt?
Ich bin jetzt Side Reliability Engineer.
Warum, weiß ich auch nicht.
Weil es sich besser anhört.
Weil man der Meinung war, die alten Jobbezeichnungen sind so outdated, overrated.
Wir benennen das einfach um.
Also ich bin exakt das gleiche wie vorher.
Ich mache exakt das gleiche wie vorher.
Aber ich bin jetzt seit Reliability Engineer.
Ja.
Insofern.
Wenigstens mehr Geld? Nö.
Das ist genau der gleiche Job, der wurde einfach umbenannt.
Was ist das?
Das ist wieder so ein Ding, wo es glaube ich keine richtige Definition dafür gibt.
Ich kann euch ein bisschen versuchen zu erklären, was ich da drunter verstehe.
Da, Side Reliability Engineer würde ich sagen, das ist jemand, der versucht mit Automatisierung und möglichst skalierbaren Infrastrukturen, äh, keine Ahnung.
Irgendwie sowas in der Richtung
Ich kann das nicht erklären
Mit
Automatisierung
Möglichst skalierbare Infrastruktursachen
Versuchen
Anwendung laufen zu lassen
Möglichst hochverfügbar
Okay, wir gucken mal
Was macht ein SAE?
Site Reliability Engineer ist ein von Google geprägtes Konzept, das Methoden der Softwareentwicklung nutzt, um den IT-Betrieb zu automatisieren und zu verzeihen.
Ziel ist es, hochgradig skalierbare und stabile Software-Systeme zu gewährleisten, während gleichzeitig...
Siehste, Chat, meine Erklärung war gar nicht so verkehrt.
Die war zwar ein bisschen
holprig und aus Märmel geschüttelt,
aber so verkehrt ist es nicht.
Wenn du deinen Job aufschreibst,
klingt es dann wie eine Stelle oder fünf.
Nee, denke ich nicht.
Da müsste ich mir mal Gedanken zu machen.
Also ich meine,
ich mache ein paar Sachen, die nicht klassisch
so Linux
äh, Feld sind, ja.
Ich programmier öfters mal ganz gern kleine Tools.
Das ist aber halt was, was ich mach
und mich auch gerne dann, ähm,
da irgendwo anders reinhänge, so nach dem Motto,
aha, da könnten wir doch irgendwas basteln.
Jetzt nicht unbedingt, weil irgendjemand gesagt hat,
Max, das wollen wir unbedingt für diese Position haben.
Ich glaub, die finden's ganz gut, dass ich das mache,
aber, ähm, das war bestimmt nix,
wo sie sich am Anfang dran gedacht haben,
wir suchen jemanden, der das auch machen kann.
Aber es ist praktisch, ne?
Wie gesagt, unsere Blockchain-Infrastruktur wird mit einem Custom-Prometheus-Exporter von mir überwacht.
Zum Teil. Nicht alles.
Das Ding ist mittlerweile, glaube ich, schon 800 Zeilen lang.
Und macht ganz, ganz viel Zeug, wo am Anfang keiner gedacht hat.
Ihr nutzt Blockchain, ja
Ich kann es euch jetzt aber nicht so sehr im Detail erzählen
Weil das Problem ist
Wenn ich euch das erzähle
Dann könnt ihr googeln und wisst sofort wo ich arbeite
Ich bin nicht mehr bei einer Bank
Ich arbeite bei einer Versicherung
Aber auch da ist das Thema
wir sind Deutschland first, ganz weit vorne mit dabei, was das Thema angeht.
Also wenn ihr irgendwelche Krypto-Währe demnächst da
Möglichkeiten seht bei eurer Versicherung, vielleicht habe ich das ja mitentwickelt.
Wärst du noch oft mit der Bahn, ja?
Okay, hier kommt die Erklärung.
Ein Site-Reliability-Engineer verantwortet die strategische Sicherstellung von Service-Reliability, Operational Excellence und Plattform-Scalability entlang der gesamten digitalen Wertschöpfungskette.
Die Rolle fungiert als zentraler Enabler für Business-Continuity-resilente Systemarchitekturen und nachhaltige Growth-Enablement-Initiatives,
in dem durch Observability-Driven Operations, Automation-First-Infrastructure-Management und Datenbasierte Reliability-Governance hochverfügbare...
Moment, das war es jetzt aber.
Natürlich, meine Rede.
Ja, also wir betreiben mittlerweile...
Mittlerweile betreiben wir Polygon-Nodes, Ethereum-Nodes, Bitcoin-Nodes und zwei unterschiedliche Frankfurter Finanzbranchen private Blockchain-Nodes.
Aber wie gesagt, ich muss jetzt gucken.
Ich will jetzt nicht zu viel erzählen, weil da kann man relativ easy danach googeln.
Ich erzähle jetzt nichts weiter dazu.
Keine Ahnung, was da...
Was ich dazu erzählen kann und was nicht.
So, wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Wir sind
reguliert hoch 10 bei uns passiert nichts illegales so viel kann ich sagen
so sind verstehen geblieben
cloud operations engineer focus and infrastructure mwd
Okay, zeigt mal her.
Ist es auch eine mit KI erstellte Stellenanzeige?
Zahlenversicherung, gut.
Ja, es gab letztens erst Kununu besten Gehälter, so ein Report.
Durchschnittsgelder nach Branchen in Deutschland.
Versicherung Platz 1
Banken Platz 2
Und dazu kommt noch Frankfurt
Und dementsprechend gibt es ganz gut Kohle
Habt ihr einen Tarifvertrag?
Ja haben wir
Aber ich werde nicht nach Tarifvertrag bezahlt
Aber haben wir
Das Gute ist
wenn das jeweilige Unternehmen
in einem Tarifvertrag ist, also ich
gehe mal davon aus, das wird bei anderen auch so, aber bei uns
ist es so, wenn du einen
außertariflichen Vertrag hast, kriegst du
trotzdem die Erhöhung aus dem Tarifvertrag.
Warum?
Weil
stellt euch vor,
ihr habt einen,
der verdient, keine Ahnung,
1000 Euro, ja, und ihr habt einen, der verdient
2000 Euro. Der hier ist
AT und der hier ist
TV.
Und
der kriegt alle paar Jahre
automatische Erhöhung und der hier nicht.
Dann überholt irgendwann
der hier den da.
Deswegen
ist bei uns so, dass du mehr oder weniger
1 zu 1 die Tariferhöhung
aus dem Tarifvertrag auch für die
AT-Verträge weitergegeben kriegst.
Das ist eigentlich sehr nice.
Das macht überhaupt nichts.
Du machst in deinem Job sicherlich auch Sachen, wo jemand, der keine Ahnung davon hat, sich denkt, was treibt er denn da eigentlich gerade.
Das ist letztendlich in fast jedem Job so, wenn du als Außenstehender zuguckst.
Also wenn du Ahnung von deinem Job hast.
90% der Leute haben ja keine Ahnung.
Egal in welchem Job.
90% der Leute sacken in ihrem Job.
Ich auch.
Das ist aber auch normal.
Man muss auch wissen, wann man keine Ahnung hat. Aber das Gute ist, wenn man sich auskennt, dann hat man relativ schnell Ahnung von einem Thema, von dem man noch vor ein paar Tagen keine Ahnung hatte. Weil man eben die Base, das Base-Knowledge hat, sich das relativ schnell anzueignen.
So, jetzt gucken wir erstmal weiter hier
Also, was ist das hier am Start?
Was haben die hier am Start?
Cloud Operations Engineer
Papierstapel waren gestern
Wir bringen das Dokumentenmanagementsystem
Also quasi sowas wie Paperless
Nur Business Enterprise
Ob diese Stellanzeige
auch per AI
geschrieben ist, so ein bisschen vom Aufbau
her könnte ich mir das vorstellen.
Was fehlt
ist,
kennt ihr das?
KI-Modelle
machen gerne diese
komischen Striche dazwischen.
also gucken wir mal mdash genau wir bringen das dokumentenmanagement der nächsten generation in
die cloud wird es davon ausgehen dass das dokumentenmanagement der nächsten system
generation schon in der cloud ist oder entwickelt und betreibt moderne hochverfügbare ecm
architekturen das sind wahrscheinlich dokumenten management systeme ich weiß
nicht was ecm bedeutet espresso coffee maschinen
enterprise content management
enterprise content management aha
Da wir unsere Lösungen sowohl in hybriden Umgebungen als auch native in der Cloud betreiben und stark auf KI-gestützte Workflows setzen, suchen wir einen passionierten Cloud-Spezialist, der neben unseren klassischen Windows- und Linux-Infrastrukturen auch unsere moderne Container-basierten KI- und LLM-Umgebungen im Backend im Griff hat.
Boah, da geht's zur Sache hier.
Deine Aufgabe. Okay, was suchen die nochmal? Lass mal gucken. Ein Cloud Operations Engineer. Okay.
infrastrukturbetrieb du verantwortest den stabilen sicheren und hochverfügbaren
betrieb unserer landschaften windows und linux stack in der cloud muss es wirklich windows sein
warum schlägt man sich mit sowas rum
wer macht das freiwillig windows server das ist doch zum kotzen
und und und gibt es wirklich irgendwelche irgendwelche maschinen nicht maschine
irgendwelche language model geschichten die auf windows besser laufen als auf linux gibt es so
was application operations du übernimmst die installation das patch management das
performance monitor das troubleshooting der backend infrastruktur gut das macht schon irgendwie sinn
Wobei, sich um die Infrastruktur, um die Backend-Infrastruktur zu kümmern,
Ist nicht wirklich Application?
Aber da wollen wir uns jetzt mal nicht drüber pepsicher sein, als der Papst.
Containerisierung und KI-Infrastruktur.
Du betreust und optimierst unsere Docker-Umgebung und stellst die Infrastruktur für unsere modernen App-KI-Server bereit.
Kein Kubernetes.
docker stilz gut macht das mit docker kann durchaus sinn machen wenn die lokale ki betreiben
mit grafikkarten und sowas also das geht auch mit kuba net ist ist halt die frage ob das nicht
komplett over engineer dann ist also kann durchaus sinn machen du bist für das hosting und den betrieb
von Large Language Models
Verantwortung und stellst sicher, dass die
KI-Modelle performant und skalierbar in
unsere ECM-Lösung integriert sind.
Äh.
Wie jetzt? Macht doch
keinen Sinn.
Also ja, du kannst das
Hosten und Betrieb von
den KI-Servern
machen, aber ob die,
dass die Modelle
performant und skalierbar in
die ecm lösung integriert sind das ist doch nicht der job desjenigen der die
model server betreibt oder sollst du auch noch die anwendung programmieren
monka w
xxh die scopes automatisierung cloud migration du optimierst bestehende
deployment und betriebsprozesse zum beispiel mittels scripting infrastructure
as code und nutzt kunden ok ja sicherheit und backup es ist auch okay
also das ist schon in ordnung
Ich glaube, das ist halt auch per KI-Unterstützung geschrieben.
Ach, hier haben wir noch was.
Okay.
Moment hier.
Okay, das bringst du mit.
Du hast eine sehr, sehr dumme Frage.
Ja, dann.
Let's go.
Benutzt du viel Cloud-Code oder andere Agents?
Ich benutze tatsächlich gar keinen Cloud-Code.
Ich benutze allerdings gerne Open-Code.
Ich bin aber nicht so der Hardcore-Agentic-Vibe-Coder,
der einen Prompt schreibt und dann 16 Agents zwei Tage dran werkeln lässt.
Ich benutze das eher als Unterstützung, wenn ich was basteln möchte, ja.
ich baue irgendwas
und dann schmeiße ich das ganz gerne mal irgendeinem Model hin,
so nach dem Motto, fällt dir noch was ein, was man besser machen könnte?
Oder so nach dem Motto,
hier, guck mal, ich habe sowas schon mal in Go gemacht,
wie würdest du das in C-Sharp machen?
Oder aber,
ich brauche 50 Endpoints,
die sich nur in diesen und diesen Dingern
unterscheiden, kannst du das mal erstellen?
Dafür verwende ich
KI.
Jetzt irgendwie
großer Hardcore-Vibe-Coder bin ich nicht.
OpenCode mit welchem LLM?
Also was ich bei OpenCode sehr nice finde ist,
dass die GLM 4.1 oder 5.1,
ich weiß gar nicht, wo wir aktuell sind,
oder GLM, warte mal.
GLM 5.1 kostenlos haben.
Das verwende ich, das China-Chinesen-Model,
das verwende ich tatsächlich hauptsächlich,
Weil ich zu geizig bin, Kohle zu bezahlen.
Die sind gar nicht schlecht.
Open Code hat GLM 5.1 kostenlos.
Mistral, bla, blub, kostenlos.
Minmax, müssen wir mal gucken.
Open Code Models.
Die Seite stimmt leider nicht immer genau.
Nein, das ist nett dabei.
Die hatten doch mal so eine Übersicht
über die Models.
Ach, hier.
Hä? Hat sich das...
Okay, was haben sie jetzt?
Okay, das hat sich geändert.
Das hat sich geändert.
Es gibt jetzt
Deepseek V4 Flash for Free.
Nemotron 3
super noch nie gehört.
For free. Big Pickle
ist GLM 5.1.
Soweit ich weiß.
Das heißt bloß anders.
Minmax M2.5 war auch eine Zeit lang
kostenlos.
Das ändert sich öfters.
Was die kostenlos anbieten.
Aber das ist richtig.
Wenn man wirklich zu geizig ist wie ich,
ordentlich Kohle reinzubuttern.
Also ganz im Ernst.
Wenn ich bereit wäre, in die Tasche zu greifen für KI-Entwickler, würde ich auch Cloud-Code verwenden.
Das ist wirklich so die, wie soll ich sagen, die schmerzfreiste Angelegenheit wahrscheinlich.
Damit hat man seine Ruhe.
Wenn man es kostenlos haben will, ist OpenCode mit den Models hier auch nicht verkehrt.
Und die Integration ist halt auch relativ easy, wenn man das quasi über die dann abrechnet.
Es gibt ja hier diesen KI-Service von denen.
Zen heißt es genau.
Du kannst aber in OpenCode auch direkt die jeweiligen Models einbinden.
Das geht auch.
Wo ich mir nicht ganz sicher bin ist
Ob
Ähm
Hier Claude Opus
Wie gut das noch in OpenCode funktioniert
Da bin ich mir nicht sicher
Weil
Anthropic hat ja letztens
Seine
API-Geschichten geändert
Wobei ich dann da auch wieder gehört hab
Sie hätten angeblich wieder
Zurückgerudert
Aber da habe ich jetzt nicht den Überblick zu
Also da bin ich mir nicht sicher
Wie gut das hier drinnen auch funktioniert
Na ja, ein Topic hat er letztens gesagt
Äh, Third Party
AP Access wollen sie restrikten
Gab einen riesen Aufschrei
Und ich glaube, dann haben sie wieder zurückgerudert
Aber, hören sagen
Keine Ahnung
Okay, was haben wir sonst noch hier
Du bringst mit
fundierte berufserfahrung in der administration von gemischten server umgebung windows server
und linux das ist halt eklig würden die sagen linux und da wäre das schon mal deutlich angenehmer
praktische erfahrungen mit docker und der orchestrierung von container landschaften
erste erfahrung oder starkes interesse ein hosting von einem zum beispiel wir
olama hugging face also olama mit huggins face habe ich tatsächlich schon gemacht unter
bereitstellung von kaisa war infrastruktur inklusive gpu passt du das habe ich mir
gedacht dass sie deswegen container deswegen docker verwenden weil du kannst das auch in
einem kubernetes cluster machen aber das ist wahrscheinlich wenn es jetzt nicht wirklich
groß wenn du nicht google bist oder microsoft dann ist es wahrscheinlich
ohne kuppern ist deutlich angenehmer
know-how im betrieb und der architektur von multi talent umgebung erfahrung mit
scripting powershell bash preisen zur automatisierung als analytisches denken
hochmodernes tech affines arbeitsumfeld mit state of the art werkzeugen cutting
edge ki und cloud tech viel raum für eigene flexible arbeit zeigen eine
gelebte home office kultur ein hochmotiviert das team in dem neue ideen
und technologische input ausdrücklich erwünscht sind top ausstellung so nahm
Wollen wir mal, was ist das?
Namenhafte Top-Klubs aus der Bundesliga.
Okay, whatever.
Also, wisst ihr was?
Ich finde das gar nicht mal...
Oder, Chat, was denkt ihr dazu?
Ich finde das gar nicht so übel.
Also, wenn man da Bock drauf hat,
ist das, glaube ich, schon was,
was ein Happy machen könnte.
Wenn man auf so KI-Geschichte...
Ich finde das gar nicht schlecht.
Das Einzige, wo ich persönlich
gar keinen Bock drauf hätte. Ist die Mischung aus
Windows-Server noch
mit dabei?
Wenn... Also das ist alles...
Das geht alles klar. Alles okay.
Ja?
Außer
Windows-Server.
Ne, was die bieten, wissen wir ja leider nicht so genau.
Ist das ein Startup oder was ist das?
Keine Ahnung.
Papst veröffentlicht...
Und was? Der Papst?
Was zum Teufel hat der Papst mit KI zu tun?
Papst veröffentlicht Enzyklika zur künstlichen Intelligenz.
Der Papst äußert sich zu KI.
Warum nicht?
Am Puls der Zeit hier der Papst
Tja
Eigentlich ist es mir ziemlich egal, was der Papst schreibt.
Auf der anderen Seite ist es aber tatsächlich ganz cool, dass er sich mit modernen Sachen beschäftigt.
Ich kann zu Gehältern für Werkstudenten so echt nichts sagen. Keine Ahnung.
Also Mindestlohn sind ja irgendwas um 14 Euro die Stunde oder sowas, gell?
Das heißt, das hier ist knapp über Mindestlohn Euro
Die Amis spinnen, ey.
Wie viel würdest du für die Stelle als Bewerber fordern?
Die hier.
Das ist echt schwer.
Das kommt auf den Laden an.
Also es ist halt die Frage, ob das realistisch ist.
Du kannst sagen, du kannst immer überall hingehen und sagen,
Alter, ich will 150k.
Aber das ist halt je nach Laden total unrealistisch.
Keine Ahnung.
ich was ist das lasst uns mal kurz lasst uns mal kurz das hier angucken ecm
dokumentensystem
wordpress wordpress dachte ich mir irgendwie schon dachte ich mir irgendwie
schon dass das wordpress seite ist okay sagt aber über das unternehmen nichts
aus.
Ich weiß nicht, wie groß
die sind oder sonst was.
Münster,
weiß ich nicht, wie da...
Keine Ahnung. Boah, ich kann halt...
Leute, ich kann mir da nur irgendwas aus den Fingern saugen.
Keine Ahnung.
Recht, sag mal, wahrscheinlich jetzt
nicht das größte Unternehmen.
Die wollen Leute mit Erfahrung haben.
Die wollen Leute mit Erfahrung.
Also es ist auf jeden Fall schon mal keine Juniorstelle.
Oder naja.
Ja, na gut.
Das könnte auch...
Na gut, fundierte Berufserfahrung.
Das stimmt schon.
Ich würde mich dem Chat mal anschließen.
So von der Größenordnung her.
Ich kann da jetzt so richtig...
Was Handfestes kann ich da nichts zu sagen.
Aber 70k klingt doch eigentlich schon mal ganz brauchbar.
Ich kenne mich nicht mit der Umgebung aus dort in Münster.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich kann eh relativ wenig sagen.
Also die einzigen Sachen, die ich halbwegs beantworten kann, sind Einstiegsgehälter.
Da kann ich von meinem Einstiegsgehalt hochrechnen.
Und ich kann euch was zur Frankfurter Finanzbranche so ein bisschen sagen, wenn es darum geht.
Bei Gehältern.
Aber ansonsten ist es nicht, als wäre ich jetzt da der große Guru, was das angeht.
Arbeite seit zwei Jahren als QA-Engineer im mobilen Bereich, im Mobile-Bereich.
Wie oft empfiehlst du, ich empfehle gar nichts, empfiehlst du in der IT das Unternehmen zu, also ich persönlich empfehle da gar nichts.
Das muss man selbst wissen.
Ich kann dir aber sagen, wie ich das gemacht habe.
Die, also wann ich Unternehmen gewechselt habe.
Das kann ich dir sagen.
Das erste war Ausbildung beim Internetprovider damals und danach wurde ich da übernommen für damals Einstiegsgehalt 2007, 33.500 Euro im Jahr.
Aber wie gesagt, das ist fast 10 Jahre her
Äh, fast 20 Jahre her
Wir haben das letztens mal hochgerechnet
Und da waren wir irgendwie bei 42k
Wäre das heute oder irgendwie sowas
Kommen wir hier, warte mal hier
Inflationsrechner
Hatten wir das hier irgendwo gerechnet?
Zeitraum von
Ne
Was?
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Okay.
33.500?
Angenommen.
Historische Preissteigerung.
Äh, what?
Äh.
Oh, Chat, ich hab's kaputt gemacht.
Ich hab's kaputt gemacht
Machen wir mal 2010
Äh
Was?
Ich check das Ergebnis nicht
Wir hatten beim Spiegel sowas, Gehaltsrechner, Inflationsgehaltrechner, genau.
Hier Bruttogehalt, 33.500, Datum der letzten Gehaltsänderung, äh, keine Ahnung.
Und jetzt gehen wir zurück auf
Äh
Okay genau so
Das sind jetzt irgendwie
46k
Also es ist hier schon richtig krass angezogen
Ja
So, also, erster Wechsel bei mir vom Job sah so aus.
Ich wurde nach der Ausbildung beim Internetprovider übernommen.
Das kann man ja nicht wirklich Topwechsel nennen.
Da habe ich dann ein paar Jahre gearbeitet.
Und ich war bei einer Niederlassung in Frankfurt.
In einer Bank damals.
Und ich kannte die Leute da schon.
Und dann kamen zwei Sachen zusammen.
Die wollten weniger abhängig sein von externen Dienstleistern, damals bei der Bank.
Und mein damaliger Arbeitgeber ging mir auf den Sack.
Ich habe dazu auch ein Video gemacht.
Und ähm...
Wenn der Chef dich verarscht, hieß das irgendwie.
Genau.
Da habe ich ein Video dazu gemacht, warum ich damals beim Provider weg bin.
Also im Prinzip kann man sagen, zwei Sachen zusammen getroffen.
Einmal dort, wo ich quasi in der Niederlassung mit dem Unternehmen, wo wir damals in der Niederlassung viel zusammengearbeitet haben,
die Bank hat gesagt, wir würden uns gerne unabhängiger machen von Dienstleistern, wollt ihr nicht zu uns kommen?
Und im gleichen Zeitraum ging mir der damalige Arbeitgeber massiv auf den Sack.
Mit Dingern, die sie getrieben haben.
Wenn du es genau wissen willst, was da war, kannst du dir das Video angucken.
Das war der erste Jobwechsel.
Dann war ich ziemlich lange da.
Ich war zehn Jahre fast dort.
Ich war über zehn Jahre da.
Ich habe mich vor meinem zehnjährigen Jubiläumsessen gedrückt.
Die machen dort immer zehnjähriges Jubiläumsessen mit dem Vorstand und so.
Also, das erste Jahr habe ich abgesagt, weil Corona war.
Und im zweiten Jahr, wo sie mich wieder hätten eingeladen, habe ich dann gekündigt.
Aber es hat nichts damit zu tun gehabt, dass ich gekündigt habe.
So, zumindest der nächste Arbeitgeberwechsel war auch wieder ähnlich gelagert.
Kombination aus Arbeitgeber geht mir auf den Keks.
Aus mehreren Gründen.
Letzter Arbeitgeber ging mir aus dem Keks.
Erstens, weil sie sich super davor gedrückt haben immer, mit zig Ausreden, warum sie nicht mehr Geld bezahlen können.
Also im Prinzip ähnliches Problem wie bei dir.
Sie haben super Ausreden immer gefunden, warum das jetzt mit mehr Geld nicht geht.
Und sie haben jedes Jahr quasi verkündet neue Rekordergebnisse.
Aber bei Geld hat er immer gesagt, oh, das ist gerade ganz, da kam ich mir irgendwann übelst verarscht vor.
Und meinem Kollege, der mit mir gewechselt ist, haben sie dann auch so Dinge versprochen wie,
also das kann ich jetzt nur aus dem seiner Sicht erzählen, weil bei mir gab es sowas nicht,
der hat auch damals zu seinem Chef gesagt, ihr erzählt mir seit drei Jahren hier schon immer was und es passiert nichts.
Und da hat er einen Zwei-Jahres-Plan mit seinem Chef gemacht, was da passieren soll in den zwei Jahren.
Und als die zwei Jahre um waren, ist halt nichts von dem Zwei-Jahres-Plan passiert.
Und er hat halt auch gesagt, nee, nee, da habe ich keinen Bock mehr drauf.
Aber mir war es im Prinzip auch so.
Also ich habe immer gesagt, Leute, wie sieht es denn hier aus?
Wie sieht es denn da aus?
Sie haben sich immer irgendwelche Ausreden einfallen lassen,
warum das Ganze nicht funktioniert und oh, ganz furchtbar schlimm.
Und der Sarg, der Nagel im Sarg oder wie sagt man das?
der Sargnagel war dann,
als sie gesagt haben,
also Homeoffice während
Corona lief richtig gut und auch danach
hieß erstmal, wir machen das weiter.
Und irgendwann haben sie gesagt, wir schaffen das mit Homeoffice
jetzt wieder zu sukzessive
ab. Und da habe ich
gesagt, nö.
Da mache ich nicht mit.
Das lief so gut und ich bin jetzt
so verwöhnt dadurch, dass mir die Bahn nicht
jeden Tag auf den Sack geht, das will ich nicht mehr.
Und die sind mir damals
nur
scheinbar quasi entgegengekommen,
sodass ich die Klappe halte,
so nach dem Motto,
ja Max, das können wir jetzt erstmal ruhig weiter so machen
und sonst wie,
aber nach ein paar Wochen
haben sie dann auch bei mir gesagt,
hier jetzt sofort wieder herkommen
und vor Ort,
da habe ich auch gesagt,
ja Moment, aber ihr habt doch gesagt,
wir können das weiter so machen.
Ja, das interessiert uns jetzt nicht mehr.
Da habe ich auch gesagt, ja gut.
Dann interessiert mich das auch alles nicht mehr.
Ich gucke mich um nach was Neuem.
Also da war es bei dem Wechsel eine Kombination aus.
Sie wollen irgendwie nicht mehr Kohle bezahlen.
In den letzten Jahren hinweg schon.
Und Homeoffice-Regelungen wurden immer weiter beschnitten.
Da habe ich gesagt, gucke ich mich nach was anderem um.
Das waren die Sachen, warum ich den Job gewechselt habe.
Und du siehst, ich bin niemand, der auf den Job wechselt und es hat trotzdem mit viel Kohle funktioniert. Also man muss nicht unbedingt immer laufend den Arbeitgeber wechseln, um mehr Geld zu bekommen.
Aber wenn es dich abfuckt auf der aktuellen Arbeit
Und du der Meinung bist
Deine Erwartung und das was die dir bieten können
Trotz mehrfacher Gespräche mit denen
Deckt sich einfach nicht
Lässt sich einfach nicht über einen Kamm
Oder so einem Strich zusammenbringen
Dann ist jetzt vielleicht eine gute Gelegenheit was zu suchen
Man muss aber halt sagen
Gerade ist es auch echt beschissen was zu finden
Für Leute mit langjähriger Berufserfahrung noch ein Ticken besser als für Juniorstellen, aber es ist trotzdem allgemein nicht gut.
Aktuell.
Du hast aber den Vorteil, einen Job zu haben.
Das heißt, aus dieser komfortablen Position heraus sucht sich es auch einfacher.
So, Frage beantwortet.
Kiel und will ich weiß nicht ob ich das richtig ausgesprochen habe
Findest du dich für noch finanzbranche die beste als althila
also wenn es um geld verdienen geht ja hat man ja auch bei der umfrage gesehen
Okay hier meine womöglich dumme frage
Was ist denn so die Schwelle vom Junior zu dem anderen?
Also, ich denke mal, nach zwei Jahren ist man kein Junior mehr.
Würde ich mal sagen.
Oder, Chad, was würdet ihr sagen?
Was sagt ihr?
An wann ist man kein Junior mehr?
Drei Jahre?
Drei Jahre
Zwei bis drei Jahre
Also ich
Ich würde sagen so zwei Jahre
Ab da kann man dann schon mal ein paar Vorstöße wagen
Und sagen Leute
So langsam kenne ich mich richtig gut aus
Mehr Kohle
Ne fünf Jahre ist zu krass
Ich will ja nicht wissen, ab wann man als Senior anfangen kann,
sondern wann man kein Junior mehr ist.
Aber wann ein Senior,
schwer zu sagen.
Acht Jahre?
Plus?
Das kann man,
es ist echt schwer,
das rein an Jahr, das musst du an den einzelnen Personen
festmachen.
Du hast Leute, das sind die übelsten Kack-Noobs
Obwohl sie diesen Job seit 20 Jahren machen
Okay
Hauptsächlich bezieht sich das zum größten Teil auf Berufserfahrung.
Ansonsten legt das jede Firma ein bisschen anders aus.
Man kann aber denke ich schon sagen, es gibt so ein paar Sachen, die schon öfters der Fall sind, auch bei unterschiedlichen Unternehmen.
Ja, also als Senior wird wahrscheinlich öfters erwartet, dass du auch ein bisschen den Überblick hast, ja, dass du auch eine Position hast, wo Leute halt auch auf dich zukommen können, so nach dem Motto, wie machen, sollten wir das architekturmäßig machen, ja, oder wie sollten wir zukünftig unsere Anwendungen aufbauen und solche Geschichten.
was denkst du wie sich der it stellenmarkt über die nächsten jahre entwickeln würden
ich glaube das bleibt erst mal so senior ist ein manager senior seiner ahnung hat also zum beispiel
wenn du irgendwie den senior java entwickler hast das ist dann halt jemand wo du hingehen
kannst oder ich bin ich bin nicht in der java entwicklung ich nehme tätig nicht nimmt es jetzt
mal von als beispiel vielleicht erzähle ich jetzt auch totalen mist aber ich würde ich würde erwarten
das ist jemand wo ich hingehen kann und sage hier gucke mal ich soll hier eine neue kleine
anwendung erstellen ich habe mir überlegt das mit spring
zu machen red es als als cash postgres als als datenbank und ich will das so
und so aufbauen hältst du das für eine gute idee
das ist so was weiß ich was ich mir durchaus vorstellen kann dass man ein
senior entwickler das fragen kann jetzt ist für eine gute idee das habe ich
überlegt hältst für eine gute idee und wir zusammen auch mal gucken was
könnte man da vielleicht noch verbessern dran das ist ja kein manager automatisch
Also ich habe bei uns zum Beispiel auf der Arbeit nicht nur mit Linux und Linux Themen
zu tun. Wir haben relativ viel
mit den Leuten zu tun,
die die Anwendung verantworten, die auf
den Linux-Kisten läuft.
Und da ist halt
auch viel Übergreifendes
dabei.
Und jetzt nicht nur beim Planen von
Wartungsarbeiten oder sowas.
Da sind dann so Dinger dabei wie
Verbindung XY ist langsam.
Okay, so.
Dann testest du ein bisschen auf Linux-Seite.
Dann rufst du vielleicht noch
beim
bei der Providersteuerung an und sagst,
hier, guck mal, wir müssen mal irgendeinen vom Dienstleister
mit dabei holen. Gleichzeitig
redest du noch mit einem, der für die Anwendung
zuständig ist. Gleichzeitig schnappst
du dir noch einen, der für die Datenbank zuständig
ist und dann guckt ihr, so führt man euch
das Ganze an. Also ich würde sagen,
als Zenob bist du auch ein bisschen übergreifender
tätig, als
nur da in deinem Kerngebiet.
Und du wirst halt auch öfters mal zu Architektursachen gefragt.
Zum Beispiel, wo es um den Aufbau unserer Blockchain-Infrastruktur ging auf der Arbeit.
Da waren zwei Leute aus meinem Team mit dran beteiligt.
Also ich plus noch einer oder noch einer plus ich plus mich dran beteiligt.
und da wärst du rein mit, ich bin Linux-Admin, der sonst nichts macht,
oder Linux-Engineer, der sonst nichts macht, nicht wirklich viel weiter gekommen.
Ich sehe immer noch den Chat von 18.17.
Ja, das liegt daran, weil ich eigentlich dazu auch was erzählen wollte.
Da wärst du als reiner, wir gucken nur auf Linux, nicht weiter gekommen.
Da mussten wir uns ganz viele Fragen stellen und da waren unter anderem auch so Fragen drin,
wenn wir es in der Cloud laufen lassen, wie können wir dann sicherstellen,
dass auf die ganzen privaten Keys und sowas keiner Zugriff drauf hat?
Und brauchen wir nicht vielleicht irgendwo in irgendeinem Rechenzentrum
einen besonders gesicherten Raum und solche Geschichten?
Das haben wir uns da alles damals gefragt, hat überhaupt nichts mit Linux zu tun.
sprich wir haben da übergreifend mit allen Leuten
die mit diesem Projekt was zu tun hatten
zusammengearbeitet, dass da eine gute Plattform
am Ende rauskommt, ja jetzt
wo das alles steht
jetzt kümmern wir uns hauptsächlich
um die Infrastruktur da
aber da war schon noch deutlich mehr drum herum mit dabei
und das sind halt so
Themen wo ich eher jetzt
einen Senior Admin oder einen Senior Entwickler sehe
dass man halt
auch mehr übergreifende Sachen macht
meint zu der fuchs ist ein guter bereich ja ist es okay jetzt wollte ich hier noch also kamo
tor hat gefragt was ist eigentlich der zweck von so einer unternehmensinternen ki wozu einen chat
bot einrichten wenn zum beispiel chat gpt bei jedem mitarbeiter zugänglich ist vielleicht denke
ich dazu wenig it perspektive aber die man am meisten nutzen weil ich hätte ja nicht wirklich
sinnvolle sachen also gibt es mehrere gründe ich lese erst noch mal fertig aus
der virtuell höchstens mal die ki fragen wollen wie morgen das wetter ist ob
dafür jetzt chat gpt genutzt wird oder die eis doch ziemlich wenn es gibt zwei
sachen zwei sachen
zwei sachen das erste ist datenschutz datenschutz ist das erste sagt der chat
auch gerade datenschutz wenn du direkt zu chat gpt gst oder zu google und so entropik ist egal
weißt du nicht was mit deinen daten passiert das ist insofern problematisch da du als unternehmen
selbst ja auch datenschutz auflagen hast oder schon öfters mal semi sensitive
sachen reinpastet und das willst du nicht irgendwie random zu einem cloud
anbieter schicken und man davon absehen selbst wenn du das machen würdest
obwohl es nicht machen solltest darfst du es auch nicht einfach machen als
erstes datenschutz sondern das zweite ist vielleicht benutzt man ja nicht einfach chat
gpt oder irgendwie von der stange sondern füttert damit seine neue die die knowledge
base das interne wiki internes ticketsystem und sonstwas und dann kannst du in so einem
chat schreiben sag mal chat ich kann mich noch daran erinnern auf dem und dem server
haben wir vor ganz langer zeit mal eine firewall freischaltung eingerichtet auf port 80 80 hast
du noch eine ahnung wer das beauftragt hat und wenn es dann die gescheiten daten hat
kann das die die ki beantworten das sind so die zwei grüne die mir einfallen für interne ki
Okay, Chat, mir wurde jetzt Silicon Valley so oft empfohlen
Ich glaube, ich fange das mal an zu gucken
Okay, das hätten wir abgehakt hier
Was kommt als nächstes?
Ist das nicht auch irgendeine
Irgendeine Zeitarbeitsfirma
Oder sowas?
IT-Dienstleister
Nee, dann CrowdStrike
Moment.
Ist das nicht...
Crowdstrike betreiben gemeinsam die nächste Phase
der Cybersicher einer Crowdstrike.
Aber übrigens, bei Crowdstrike ist auch genau das passiert,
was ich gesagt habe im Vorfeld.
Ähm... Moment.
Im Prinzip ist genau das passiert, was ich gesagt habe.
Nach ein paar Wochen interessiert es keine Sau mehr.
Eigentlich hätte man, eigentlich hätte ich sagen müssen, Max, du vertraust in deine Predictions so sehr, dass du jetzt hier volle Pulle Crowdstrike kaufst, als es mal billig war.
Tch, ich habe ein Problem, ich müsste jetzt eigentlich was essen, aber wir machen noch ein bisschen weiter, ich habe ja noch Zeit, ich esse einfach nebenbei ab und zu ein bisschen von meinem Apfel,
Ich fand übrigens auch noch eine Sache, die ich eben hier beim Durchscrollen gelesen habe.
Ja, genau das hier.
Das fand ich auch gut.
Ich finde, das trifft es auch ganz gut.
Ein Senior hat auch häufiger eher seltene Probleme auf dem Tisch gehabt.
Standardprobleme werden im Schlaf gelöst und kommen mir im Planung meistens...
Also das stimmt tatsächlich, das sehe ich bei uns auch.
wenn es da um Probleme geht,
wo sich andere schon
die Zähne dran ausgebissen haben.
Da setzt man dann auch mal ein paar
der erfahrene Linux-Checker
dran.
Wir haben da teilweise schon
abgedrehte Sachen rausgekriegt.
Wir haben zum Beispiel
das, ich habe ein schönes Beispiel dafür.
Ich hoffe, ich kriege das noch halbwegs zusammen.
Wir haben das Problem,
dass irgendwas mit den google cloud tools nicht funktioniert hat ich weiß
nicht mehr genau was ich krieg's nicht mehr zusammen ich weiß nur dass google
cloud hat übelst rum gespackt manchmal aber nicht immer manchmal
und haben wir uns den arsch gebissen hat dieser kaktus warum geht das nicht und
ich bin dann irgendwann drauf gekommen
ich bin dann drauf gekommen und zwar durch bauchgefühl und ihr wisst da habe
ich viel von durch bauchgefühl und ich glaube dass das was ist was echt so einen
einen erfahrenen Admin von einem neuen Admin oder von einem Admin, muss ja kein Admin sein, ja, Entwickler geht genauso oder irgendwie von jemandem, der erfahren ist in dieser Position, jemand, der Neues unterscheidet.
Man glaubt gar nicht, wie weit man mit Bauchgefühl oftmals kommt. Ich meine damit jetzt nicht, ah, mein Bauch sagt mir, das ist eine doofe Idee, das sollen wir nicht machen.
Das ist als Begründung schlecht.
Aber so nach dem Motto,
bleiben wir mal bei dem Beispiel.
Mach's gut, der F-Programm, bleib mal bei dem Beispiel.
Ich hab das Ding gestartet und gesehen,
das hat immer mal wieder Probleme in einem komischen Intervall.
Und mein Bauchgefühl hat mir gesagt,
das muss irgendein Check im Hintergrund sein.
Vielleicht irgendein Update-Check,
der checken will bei Google,
ob man die aktuelle Version hat
und dann timeoutet und hängt.
Das hat nicht so ein Bauchgefühl.
Dass das irgendwas, irgendein automatischer Check ist, der nicht jedes Mal läuft, sondern keine Ahnung, einmal am Tag.
Ich glaube, es war auch das erste Mal am Tag, wo man das gestartet hat, lief es 15 Minuten und danach immer schnell.
Irgendwie so war das.
Da habe ich gesagt, es muss doch irgendein automatischer Check.
Und ich habe dann Wiresharked, zwei, drei Stunden.
Und das war es auch.
Das war irgendein Request gegen die Google, gegen irgendeine Google-AP.
ob man die aktuellsten Google-Tools verwendet.
Und der timeoutete einfach auf dem System.
Und deswegen hing das ewig beim ersten Ausführer am Tag.
Und ich glaube, das macht auch einen guten...
Es ist wurscht, wie du es nennst, ja?
Aber das macht auch einen guten Admin, einen guten Entwickler aus,
wenn er das schon eine Weile hat,
dass er in seinem Bereich ganz guten Instinkt hat,
in welche Richtung das geht.
Guck mal, wir hatten es so oft hier im Stream schon.
Könnt ihr euch noch an das Video erinnern?
Also ich will jetzt keine krasse Selbstlobreisung machen, ja, nur als Beispiel. Könnt ihr euch noch an das Video erinnern, wo es drum ging, warum bei Trackmania die Strecke als Cheating markiert wurde, obwohl es legit war?
Erinnert sich noch einer an dieses Video, was wir geguckt haben, mit diesem Trackmania überprüft im Hintergrund, ob die Strecke auch...
Also, Trackmania simuliert im Hintergrund... Also, das Problem war folgendes.
Irgendjemand hat einen Trackmania-Weltrekord aufgestellt, aber der Server vom Anbieter von Trackmania hat gesagt, nein, das ist gecheatet.
und das Ganze funktionierte so
Trackmania hatte eine Simulation
im Hintergrund laufen, die quasi die Strecke
nochmal mit exakt dem gleichen Input
und Random Seed abgefahren ist
und nur wenn das simulierte
Trackmania auf dem im Server
das gleiche Ergebnis hatte
oder sag mal ein nahezu
nicht abweichendes Ergebnis hatte, von dem
was eingeschickt wurde, dann war das legit
so, und die hatten das Problem
dass bei dieser einen Strecke
obwohl es legit war, live im Stream erspielt wurde, der Trackmania-Server gesagt hat, diese Strecke ist gecheatet.
Und eines der ersten Sachen, die ich gesagt habe, ist G-Lip C-Version.
Könnt ihr euch noch daran erinnern?
Das war reines Bauchgefühl.
G-Lip C-Version.
Und am Ende war das genau das Problem.
G-Lip C-Version vor Ubuntu 20.04.
Vor Ubuntu 20.04
Lief die Strecke fehlerfrei durch
Und nach Ubuntu 20
Ne umgedreht
Vor Ubuntu
Ne ne ne ne
Es war vor Ubuntu 24.04
Ähm
Failte die Strecke immer
Nach Ubuntu 24.04
Wurde die Strecke immer korrekt verifiziert
Und das war weil die bei einem G-Lip C Update
Irgendwelche Funktionen
Die Zahlen gerundet haben
Angepasst haben
Wie soll man auf sowas kommen?
Das meine ich ja, Bauchgefühl
Ich liege erstaunlich oft
Mit der Intuition
In welche Richtung könnte es gehen
Richtig
Ich kann oftmals auch nicht erklären, warum
Sondern ich glaube, das
Zeichnet auch ganz gute
Seniorentwickler, Senioradmins
Aus, dass sie einen ganz guten
Instinkt für haben, in welche Richtung das Problem
Gehen könnte, das heißt nicht, dass du
Alles weißt
Ich habe von so viel mehr Sachen kein Plassenschimmer, wie ich Ahnung habe, ja
Aber ich habe meistens ein ganz gutes Bauchgefühl, in welche Richtung es geht
Ich habe auch schon komplett, ich habe auch schon komplett, ähm
Ich habe auch schon komplett Mist erzählt
Falsche Compile-Flex-Bauch
Ja, ich hatte, ich hatte mehrere Sachen vermutet bei dem Video
G-Lib C und, äh, Compiler-Optimierung
Ich habe vermutet, sie kompilieren das eine mit dem Visual Studio Compiler für Windows und das andere mit, keine Ahnung, LVM oder GCC unter Linux in irgendwelche Compiler-Optimierung.
Das war falsch, aber GLP-C war richtig.
Gibt es da ein Video zu? Ja.
Track.
Track Mania.
Ähm
Okay, warte mal
Trackmania Linux
Video
Ähm
Okay, ich hab keine Ahnung
ehrlich gesagt, wie das hieß
Ey, wie hieß denn das?
Könnten jetzt, wir könnten jetzt im Stream Archiv nachgucken.
Warte mal, Wobblords.tv.
Track.
Nicht Streamtitel.
Datum.
Trackmania?
Okay, hier.
Trackmania.
Das ist Trackmania oder sowas.
Was?
Was ist Trackmania?
Hopp.
investigating the mystery behind my deleted world record
ja
der indiziert alle meine streams
ich kann dafür aber
keinerlei credit
taken das hat alles
das series max programmiert
und sebaro hat den server gehostet
ich hab damit nix zu tun aber das archiv
ist mega pogu
Äh
Investigating
Deleted World Record
Hier, das ist das Video
Wo ich gerade drüber geredet habe
Okay, das war bei Hardcore Sidetracked, oder?
Junior DevOps
Engineer, Consultant
MonkaS, Moment, hä?
Sind das zwei Jobs in einem?
Junior DevOps Engineer
Consultant Infrastructure Automation.
Ja, was jetzt?
Also,
die meinen wahrscheinlich,
du machst hauptsächlich als
DevOps Engineer dann Infrastructure Automation.
Das passt ja auch gut dazu.
Ähm,
Moment.
wird dort Text to Speech verwendet
und wenn ja,
wird dort Speech to Text und wenn ja,
ich glaube mit Whisper.
Max, bist du da? Bist du am Start?
Du warst vorhin da,
keine Ahnung. Ich glaube Whisper ist das
im Hintergrund.
Ich glaube Whisper
läuft da im
im Hintergrund.
Und der Sebarro hatte mal irgendeinen Server, wo sogar eine Grafikkarte drin war für Whisper.
Bin mir aber nicht sicher, wie es jetzt ist.
Im Discord kannst du den Max fragen.
Der kann dir das genau erklären, ja.
Chat, Chat.
Ich habe übrigens überlegt,
dass diese Entscheidung müssen wir aber nicht heute treffen.
Ich bin in letzter Zeit selbst nicht mehr so aktiv.
Und im Discord eigentlich auch selten.
Und so richtig krassen Mehrwert hat der Discord doch gar nicht.
Ich hab mir überlegt, ob wir den Discord vielleicht einfach wieder einstampfen sollten.
Aber will ich nicht einfach so machen, weil es gibt ja immer noch Leute, die den gerne benutzen.
Okay.
Okay, dann lassen wir den Discord offen.
Ihr habt schon recht.
Ja, gerade in den Technik-Channels.
Ich weiß, ich weiß, dass da viele drauf sind, auch viele noch was schreiben.
Aber ich dachte mir so, wirklich ein Mehrwert?
Aber passt, ich mach nix.
Wenn ihr sagt, ist nice, dann promote ich das auch weiter und kost nix, das stimmt.
Jaja, habt ihr schon recht.
Also, was wollen die hier haben?
Werden auch Sie Teil der SVA-Community?
Bla bla bla bla.
You build it, you run it. Cloud-Native. Open Source. Spaß an der Arbeit.
Respekt vor Kollegen. So stellt sich unser über 100-köpfiges deutschlandweites Team auf.
Verbindet sich und setzt innovative Projekte um.
Ah, ja.
Doch, ja, wie gesagt,
ihr habt mich überzeugt, ich mach nix.
Ich mach nix.
Das bleibt alles so, wie es ist,
der Discord. Keine Sorge.
Ich lass alles so, wie es ist.
Und ich verspreche euch, ich gucke auch öfters mal rein
in nächster Zeit.
So.
Ihre Aufgaben.
Technische Begleitung von IT-Projekten und Umsetzung
der erforderlichen IT-Infrastruktur.
Okay, das ist ja nun wirklich
sehr, sehr breit gefasst, oder?
Technische Begleitung von IT-Projekten,
Umsetzung der erforderlichen IT-Infrastruktur.
Das ist sehr, sehr weit gefasst.
Zu einem DevOps-Engineer kann das durchaus passen.
Ja, aber das ist sehr breit gefasst.
Implementierung von Cloud-Lösungen,
Automatisierung von Infrastruktur.
Das ist auch enorm weit gefasst.
Das kann ja alles sein.
Von der VM auf Hetzner zu irgendeiner Kubernetes-Installation auf AWS oder bei Google irgendein kontinentübergreifender Cluster oder was, das kann ja alles sein.
Unterstützung des Vertriebsteams durch technische Expertise in der Pre-Sales-Phase.
Oh ne, heißt das etwa, du musst da zu Terminen mit, wo du dann auf technischen Erklärbär machen musst?
Das wäre ja nichts für mich.
Das wäre ja gar nichts für mich.
Technischer Support und Weiterentwicklung
der Kundensysteme Monkeys.
Aber das ist, das ist, das ist
das ist total breit gefärbt.
Also da kann man sich jetzt alles
und nichts drunter vorstellen unter
den drei Punkten.
Okay, was wollen
sie haben?
Grundkenntnisse oder Interesse an Bereichen wie Linux-Betriebssystem, Automatisierung mit Konfigurationsmanagement,
Bereitstellung mit Infrastructure as Code, Cloud-Plattformen...
Ja.
Okay, sag mal konkret.
Wahrscheinlich Terraform, wahrscheinlich Ansible.
cloud plattformen ja es ja aws gcp manche leute sind auch so abgetreten haben was in der oracle
cloud läuft die oracle cloud nicht bei google war da nicht irgendwas oder bringe ich jetzt
durcheinander oder bei alibaba bereitschaft sich mit tools zur infrastrukturautomatisierung
Automatisierung, Verwaltung, Vertrauenswahn, gute Kommunikation.
Also die Stellenanzeige hat, finde ich, irgendwie sehr wenig Substanz.
Alles und nix.
Finde ich sehr vage, diese Stellenanzeige, ehrlich gesagt.
Überzeugt mich jetzt nicht so sehr.
Ein Senior Linux System Engineer.
Da bin ich ja mal gespannt.
leading forward arbeite parko net in spannenden digitalen themen und prägen für die öffentliche
verwaltung monka ist verteidigung und unternehmen entwickeln wir moderne und nachhaltige end-to-end
Endlösungen.
So machen wir unsere Kunden
heute stark und bereit für die Zukunft.
Aha.
Gibt's dann da irgendwelche
Drohnenstationen
oder so?
Also was machen wir? Das sind deine Aufgaben.
Du wirst in unserem Hosting-Bereich
mitarbeiten und dabei unter anderem
folgende Technologien nutzen. Also was suchen die nochmal?
Moment.
Ne AC-130 Remote steuern.
Ja genau.
Wartet mal. Moment, Moment. Hatten wir nicht noch
irgendwo hier moment haltet euch die ohren zu kann man so selten verwenden
also was haben die denn hier für einen senior oder für ein linux system
Ingenieur. Linux, Debian,
Ubuntu, Suse.
Oh, please, geh weg.
Oder Red Hat.
Aber geht klar. Außer Suse.
Muss es wirklich Suse sein?
Red Hat ist ja schon teilweise
painstchampig genug.
Wir sind uns einig, Chat.
Chat, Hand aufs Herz, Debian ist das
einschware, oder?
Ich verdiene zwar mein Geld
indirekt auch mit Dreaded, aber trotzdem, Debian
ist das einzig wahre.
Wenn du Support willst,
dann bleibt dir halt nichts anderes da, als der Kram
hier übrig.
Aber Debian ist das Beste. Verkackt Debian
nicht gerade. Inwiefern?
Inwiefern verkackt Debian?
Debian laufen
viele Entwickler weg. Moment,
die haben nicht das Problem, also das letzte,
Post, den ich gelesen habe, ist nicht,
dass ihnen die Entwickler weglaufen,
sondern sie finden einfach nicht genug neue
Entwickler.
Ja.
Also im Enterprise-Umfeld muss man sagen,
ist es eindeutig Red Hat, mit
Abstand.
Gefolgt von
wahrscheinlich Ubuntu
und vielleicht danach
Suse.
Ich habe
absolut keine Ahnung, warum man Suse benutzen sollte.
Die einzige
Kiste, die ich mal betreuen
musste, die Suse Linux war,
war eine Kiste für
eine Telefonanlage.
CentOS gibt es nicht mehr, aber es gibt ja sowas wie
Alma Linux.
Die
also
Suse für eine Telefonanlage hatten wir mal.
Weil das die einzige Plattform war, die der Anbieter
unterstützt hat.
Ubuntu hat jetzt eingeführt, dass du Sternchen bei Sudo siehst.
Ich weiß.
Ubuntu hat die Rust Core Utils eingeführt.
Wovon ich, ehrlich gesagt, überhaupt kein Fan bin.
Fedora.
Nee, Fedora ist jetzt eher nicht das.
Wird da eigentlich selten eingesetzt.
Das ist eher was auf dem Desktop.
Also, wenn es in Red Hat sein soll
und man möchte keine Lizenzgebühren bezahlen,
Dann kann man Alma Linux oder Rocky Linux verwenden.
Dann kommt oftmals die Frage auf Max, was soll ich denn nehmen?
Rocky Linux oder Alma Linux, wenn ich einen freien Red Hat Nachbau haben möchte?
Für doch auch von Red Hat, das stimmt.
Da muss ich zu sagen, oder da hätte ich noch vor ein paar Wochen gesagt,
keine Ahnung, ich habe keine großartige Erfahrung mit beidem,
aber
die letzten paar Sicherheitslücken
die wir hatten, was
Dirtyfrag und Copyfail angeht
da war Alma Linux
für mich
zumindest so nach außen sichtbar
deutlich präsenter
und schneller
und klarer
nachzuvollziehen was wie wo gepatcht ist
Alma Linux war eines der ersten Distributionen
die Testkörnel
angeboten haben bei Dirtyfrag
Rocky war super schlank
Ne, super schlank fällt mir
eher Alpine ein
Sowohl Alma Linux
auch als Rocky Linux
Das ist quasi ein Red Hat
mit den Copyright Sachen entfernt
Also jetzt würde ich
mit dem Halbwissen
aus den letzten zwei Sicherheitslücken
würde ich tatsächlich eher auf Alma Linux setzen
Wenn ich mal irgendwie wieder in die Verlegenheit
kommen sollte
eine Umgebung mit Red Hat Systemen
versorgen zu müssen, die nicht echtes Red Hat sind.
Bei meinem letzten Arbeitgeber
hatten wir das so.
Da hatten wir Red Hat, aber
wir hatten kein richtiges Red Hat. Wir hatten CentOS.
Als CentOS noch CentOS war.
Und die Systeme,
wir hatten von allen Systemen
ein System mit einem offiziellen Red Hat drauf
und lizenziert.
Und immer wenn ein System
dieses Typs Probleme
hatte, haben wir bei Red Hat
ein Ticket, und wir ein Ticket gebraucht haben,
haben wir bei Red Hat ein Ticket aufgemacht
und
die Probleme hatten halt immer zufälligerweise
die Systeme mit offiziellem
Red Hat, die lizenziert waren.
Und der Red Hat Support
war oftmals enorm useless.
Okay, du wirst in unserem Haus...
Also, Debian, Ubuntu,
Suse Linux, Suse Linux
Enterprise... Was heißt denn
überhaupt?
Suse Linux Enterprise System?
Was heißt denn Sles überhaupt?
Senterprise Server.
Suse Linux Enterprise Server
oder Red Hat Enterprise Linux.
Zum Glück
zum Glück kein Oracle
Unbreakable Linux.
Also Oracle hatte wirklich
mal ein
Red Hat kompatibles System,
was sich Unbreakable Linux nannte.
Virtualisierung
KVM libvirt. Okay.
Automatisierung.
Puppet. Alter, dass ich
das nochmal sehe.
Kein Ende.
Puppet, Alter.
Das benutzt noch jemand.
Boah, wie lange habe ich das schon nicht mehr gesehen?
Das ist Server-Automatisierung.
Lange bevor es Ansible gab.
Ja, Chef gab es auch noch.
Das ist immer, du findest zu Puppet noch nicht mal
Example-Code gescheit
Soulstack, ja, ich erinnere mich
Ich erinnere mich dran
Das ist ein bisschen
Ruby angehaucht, Puppet, also Puppet selbst
Ist in Ruby entwickelt
Programmiert
Und
Ja, so sieht das aus
Puppet, das habe ich schon wirklich
ewig. Das habe ich bestimmt schon
sieben Jahre
oder so nicht mehr live im Einsatz
gesehen.
Kennst du Puppet Bowl?
Ist wie Ensemble nur Puppet? Ne, habe ich noch nie gehört.
Eine coole
Sache hatte Puppet.
Das hatte einen richtig guten
ähm, äh,
wie heißt das?
Noob
hieß das bei Puppet. Noob.
So ein Try Run.
Wo du genau gesehen hast, was es machen würde
Das fand ich eigentlich
Also ich fand Puppet an sich gar nicht schlecht
Aber dass heute noch Puppet-Leute gesucht werden
Ist wirklich selten
Benutzt man zum Monitoren kein Check-MK mehr?
Doch, immer noch
Monitoring hast du alles mögliche
Du hast Check-MK
Du hast Zabbix
Du hast manche Leute, die haben noch Nagios
manche leute sind so massen schließlich und verwenden ptg auf windows manche
stricken sich ja monitoring selbst mit graf anna prometheus alert manager
manche verwenden ich in gar in zinger wie man das ausspricht manche liebere
nms open ms und was noch alles gibt es gibt sich monitoring systeme das
einzig doofe dabei ist es gibt finde ich kein monitoring system was ich gut finde
PRTG nicht gut.
Doch, ich glaube, PRTG an sich ist gar nicht so schlecht.
Aber PRTG läuft nur auf Windows, was es halt schlecht macht.
Ich will doch nicht nur für mein Monitoring-System einen Windows-Server betreiben müssen.
Würde PRTG unter Linux laufen, hätte ich es mir wahrscheinlich auch schon mal näher angeguckt.
Ich sage nicht, dass PRTG selbst schlecht ist.
Von dem, was man so liest, ist es gar nicht übel.
Aber es wäre für mich...
Es ist für mich schlecht.
Weil es nicht unter Linux läuft.
Es gibt kein Monitoring-System,
was ich wirklich rundum gut finde.
Für Metriken und Sachen,
wo es halt viele Messwerte gibt,
ist Prometheus oder Victoria Metrix
sicherlich mit das Beste.
Aber so für klassisches Monitoring
ist ab ist dauer letzter eingeloggt der user abgelaufen und solche dinge kann
man sich das kann man sich zwar alles mit graf anna prometheus alert manager
zusammenbauen sind aber die klassischen sachen wie
tabics und check mk nicht verkehrt er kann jetzt ja nicht wirklich nennt
monitor graf anna ist ein das was der name sagt ein frontend für
Visualisierung, für
Metrikvisualisierung ist Grafana.
Für so
Dinger wie...
Also du kannst,
ich meine, du kannst in Grafana
mehr oder weniger alles dir selbst
irgendwie zusammenbauen, ja?
Wenn du die Daten dafür hast.
Und Grafana
ist meiner Meinung nach auch für diesen Anwendungszweck
das Beste, was es gibt.
Aber trotzdem
finde ich, hat so klassisches Zeug
wie beispielsweise
Zabbix
durchaus seine Daseinsberechtigung.
Wenn du nämlich sehen willst, ey, guck mal hier,
Systemübersicht,
Ping Alert
um 13.20 Uhr
zuletzt und sowas.
Man kann sich da alles irgendwie behelfen
mit Tabellendarstellung in Grafana,
aber Grafana
in Kombination mit, sagen wir mal,
Prometheus oder Victoria Matrix,
das ist kein
100%iger Ersatz
für klassische Monitoring-Lösungen
wie Nagios oder Zabbix
oder CheckMK.
Das hat unterschiedliche Stärken.
Du kannst, also nehmen wir mal
Zabbix und Grafana Prometheus.
Du kannst in beidem
nahezu alles abbilden.
Aber Zabbix
ist, was Metriken
Collecten angeht und
Dashboards und Graphen halt
nicht so dolle
und Grafana Prometheus
ist halt so, was dieses klassische
Up-Down-Monitoring-History-Übersicht
angeht, nicht so geil
wie Zabbix. Oder solche
Checks zum Beispiel
alerte mich 60 Tage
bevor das Zertifikat abläuft.
Jaja, das kannst du
mit Grafana alles darstellen.
Da ist halt viel Selbstgebastel dabei.
Und Alertmanager.
Das ist deutlich
einfacher in Zabbix.
geregelt
Das ist beides nicht so ein hundertprozentiger Ersatz für das andere
Ok, gucken wir mal weiter. Monitoring Grafana Prometheus I Chinga
Noch nie live benutzt, keine Ahnung. Ich habe sie mal irgendwann installiert und gedacht, warum sollte man das verwenden?
Also im Business Enterprise Umfeld kenne ich nur als Monitoring Lösungen Grafana Prometheus
von früher beim Provider
noch
Nagios. Ich hab ja, ich hab's ja schon oft gesagt,
ich hab ein Herz für Nagios, ja.
Ich bin immer noch
kleiner Nagios-Fanboy, auch wenn ich
keine neue Nagios-Installation
betreiben möchte
und installieren möchte, aber ich mag
irgendwie Nagios. Wahrscheinlich, weil
es mein erstes größeres Projekt in der
Ausbildung war, Nagios
zu
aufzusetzen und zu
erneuern.
So, also.
Grafana Prometheus,
Nagios beim Provider,
Zabbix, CheckMK.
Das sind die Monitoring-Systeme,
die ich im Business Enterprise Umfeld selbst schon
betreut und benutzt und
verwendet hab.
Und Sachen, das Server damit überwacht hab.
Hattet ihr
bei der Bank nicht Zabbix?
Korrekt.
Da hatten wir Zabbix.
Wir haben dann aber die letzten Jahre über sehr
viel aus Zabbix ausgelagert
in Prometheus Grafana, wo es um
Metric Collection ging, so
Garbage Collector Runs und so
Gedöns. Das konntest du zwar alles machen
in Zabbix, aber so geil war das nicht.
Das war in Grafana Prometheus viel besser.
Weil ganz ehrlich,
in einem Graf rein, rauszoomen,
sich da was angucken, das ist so viel
besser in Grafana als diese hässlichen Grafen
in Zabbix.
macht sabics auch nrp sabics hat einen eigenen agent
nrp sonar johs ding sabics hat den sabics agent ok guck mal weiter infrastruktur ha proxy open vpn
key cloak dns dhcp ich muss sagen es wirkt ein wenig random diese aufzählung
wirkt irgendwie ein bisschen zusammengewürfelt server apache kein engine
PostgreSQL, MySQL, MongoDB.
Von uns selbst entwickeltes Tooling wie zum Beispiel Automainter.
Moment, gibt es dazu irgendwas?
The fuck?
HTML von 1998.
Also das UI ist wirklich oldschool.
Aber ganz im Ernst, Leute.
Lieber ein ordentlich flottes, gut lesbares,
UI
als irgendwas mit Endless Scroll
und Animationen und Gedöns.
Hast du das von Atlassian mitbekommen
wegen dem YouTube-Video?
Nee.
Guck mal.
Jira-Ticket.
Eindeutig.
Eindeutig Jira.
Was hat denn Atlassian auf YouTube getrieben?
Wir gucken jetzt erstmal die Stellenanzeige hier fertig.
Was? Moment, Moment, Moment.
Werde ich jetzt gerickrolled, wenn ich das hier anklicke?
Ich war bei Atlassian zu spät.
Warum?
Achso, der wurde von Atlassian entlassen und um die zu ärgern,
erzählt er jetzt ein bisschen was über die nähere Infrastruktur oder wie?
Oh ja.
warum nicht gucken wir uns aber nicht an ich muss jetzt erst noch mal was essen
gleich er hat nur erzählt was er da gemacht hat okay du begleitest noch okay
du gestaltest zukunftsumgebung du agierst als ansprechpartner mentor für
die professional und junior system engineers das wünschen wir von ihr
weitreichende erfahrung möglichst viel unserer oben gestehenden fundierte
Erkenntnisse. Du weißt nicht nur, was,
wie du etwas tust, sondern auch, warum
du es tust.
Ich weiß oftmals
nicht, was ich mache und auch nicht, warum.
Da bin ich nicht der richtige
Senior Linux Engineer für die hier.
Jetzt sag mal so, warum, doch, warum,
warum weiß ich? Vielleicht, weil
es kaputt ist oder weil es irgendeiner
haben will, weil er es ins Ticket geschrieben hat, aber
warum die das letztendlich
dann wollen, das verstehe ich auch oftmals nicht.
Letztens wollte irgendeiner
einen ganz merkwürdigen Cron-Shop haben
das weiß ich noch
der hat einen Cron-Shop eingerichtet
der hat alle
.log Dateien
gelöscht, aber .txt Dateien
dagelassen
in diesem Verzeichnis
und da habe ich auch reingeschrieben
sicher, dass du nur alle .log Dateien
löschen willst, weil da gibt es
ganz viele .txt Dateien, die sind viel
größer und alles und... Ne, ne, nur die
Log-Dateien.
Okay. Du bist der Experte
für die Anwendung, wenn du das so haben willst.
Mach ich.
Also ich hab absolut keine Ahnung, warum ich
das tue.
Und was ich tue, wusste ich auch nicht so genau.
Aber der wollte das so haben.
Ja.
Und ich bin meiner...
meinem Job als Senior-Linux-
Stelzer
gerecht geworden. Ich hab nochmal rückgefragt,
ob er sich sicher ist, dass das so richtig
ist und er hat gesagt, ja,
das Problem ist, es gibt manchmal
Leute, die können
es nicht, also ich sage nicht, dass es da so war,
ich bin mir relativ sicher, es war nicht so, ja,
ich sage aber, das Problem, was ich auch schon hatte mit
Tickets, es gibt Leute,
die haben Probleme
damit einzuräumen,
wenn sie was vergessen haben.
Ich sage doch nicht, oder was
falsch verstanden haben oder
an was nicht gedacht haben.
Also sprich, Leute,
die denken,
Sie dürfen irgendwelche Fehler auf gar keinen Fall zugeben.
Das gibt's.
Und das ist natürlich dann blöd, wenn einer ein Feindbefehl zum Löschen reinschreibt.
Ja, man antwortet drauf, bist du sicher, dass du die Logdateien willst, nicht TXT?
Der merkt dann, oh Mist, ich wollte auch die TXT, kann es aber nicht zugeben, aus welchen Gründen auch immer.
Und beharrt dann drauf, dass die Logdateien nur gelöscht werden müssen.
Das ist dann halt richtig dumm für alle,
weil dann macht zwei Monate später jemand
anderes ein Ticket auf, bitte neuen Job einrichten,
jetzt auch TXC-Dateien.
Wie gesagt, ich sage nicht, dass es da jetzt so
gewesen ist. Ich gehe davon aus,
dass der will das wirklich so haben.
So. Bei Interesse
ist ein Einsatz in folgenden
Bereichen möglich. Netzwerk
und Infrastruktur Linux, Uniper,
DDoS-Abwehr, Projektarbeit,
Ab... Was?
Oh, da wäre ich am Start hier.
Programmierung von Tools zur internen Nutzung.
Da hätte ich Bock drauf.
Man mache ich bei uns ja auch schon öfters.
Also,
ich will da nicht hin. Ich suche keinen Job, ne?
Für Leute, die jetzt reinkommen und denken, was ich hier mache.
Ich bin super happy, da wo ich bin.
Jo.
Was sagen wir zu dieser Stellenanzeige?
Ich finde die gar nicht so schlecht.
Die schreiben wenigstens mal ein paar konkrete Sachen rein.
Wenn es auch teilweise ein bisschen sehr zusammengewürfelt wirkt.
HA-Proxy, OpenVPN, Keyclock, DNS, DHCP.
Ja, okay.
Aber ich finde die Stellanzeigen nicht verkehrt.
Wenig Gelaber.
Sachen, womit ich als Techniker was anfangen kann, wenn ich sie lese.
Das hier geht auch klar.
dass sie schreiben, wo du dich
was du noch, wo du dich
hin entwickeln kannst, ist falsch.
Wo du auch noch weitere Möglichkeiten hast,
ist, finde ich, auch gut.
Ja, über das, was sie suchen, hinaus.
Ich fand die
Stellenanzeige gar nicht so übel hier,
Cornett.
Tschätke,
euer Fazit?
Ich hol jetzt mal ein Stück Apfel.
Ich find's halt verkehrt.
Was ist jetzt die geilste Stellenanzeige ever,
die ich je gelesen hab?
Nee, aber gehört auf jeden Fall zu den besseren.
Was sagen sie zur Bezahlung?
Natürlich nix.
Wen es interessiert, kann ich ja bei der Stefanie Welsing melden.
Oder hier hinschreiben.
D.F.
Bald müssen sie ja.
Ich bin mal gespannt.
Ich bin mal echt gespannt, wie das wird.
Ich könnte wetten, diese Sache mit
man muss Bezahlung angeben.
Das wird wieder so sein, dass sie dann hinschreiben
Gehaltsspanne
30 bis 150k.
Da kannst du dann halt genauso wenig mit anfangen.
Bei Kununu wollen wir mal gucken.
Okay.
Conet Holding GmbH als Arbeitgeber.
Ja.
Wertung.
Man darf bei diesen Dingern hier immer nicht vergessen.
Leute, die auf solche Bewertungsplattformen gehen,
gehen da hauptsächlich hin, weil sie schlechte Erfahrungen gemacht haben
und drücken schlechte Bewertungen rein.
Das heißt, man kann davon ausgehen,
wenn die Bewertung, meine Interpretation der Sache,
wenn die hier ganz gut sind,
Dann sind die wahrscheinlich...
Also wenn die nicht hier total mies sind,
dann sind die wahrscheinlich wirklich ganz gut.
Also ich würde sagen,
das hier ist eine ziemlich gute Bewertung.
Ja, vielleicht haben sie sich auch zig Fake-Bewertungen reingedrückt.
Keine Ahnung, glaube ich aber mal nicht.
AI generiert Zusammenfassung.
Okay.
Was ich viel interessanter finde, sind so richtig krass negative Bewertungen.
Hier, der zum Beispiel. Viele Worte, keine Taten.
Leider immer mehr auf dem Absteigen erst zwischen Meetings.
Das ist...
Ich sage nicht, dass das nicht stimmt.
Das wird aus seiner Sicht sicherlich so sein.
Aber es ist oftmals auch so, Leute, die wirklich sehr lange bei Unternehmen sind,
die haben manchmal so einen Bias, ja.
Dass alles, was sich geändert hat, im Vergleich zu den ersten 3, 4, 5 Jahren, wo sie da waren, war nur negativ.
Ja.
Was? Grüße gehen raus
an LSI? Das ist ein Raid-Controller,
oder?
Oder so ein
HBA ist das.
Meinst du,
Meinst du, dein HBA liest Twitch-Chat?
Das wär's mal was, Chat.
Twitch-Chat.
Twitch-Chat plays HBA.
Jetzt nicht mehr.
Wieso?
Weil er jetzt abgeraucht ist.
Sadge.
F, Leute.
Wir brauchen einmal F in den Chat.
für den LSI
92118IHBA
07, Leute.
F oder 07?
07.
Okay.
Dann gucken wir mal Gehälter.
70k.
Berater, IT-Berater, Softwareentwickler, Systemingenieur, IT-System...
Na, das ist aber schon wirklich jetzt nicht so geil.
Wollen die?
Wollen die einen Senior Linux System Engineer mit 50k abspeisen?
Das wäre jetzt aber schon...
echt wenig.
Gucken wir mal hier.
Du musst bei Systemengine...
Systemengine...
Okay.
Aber sag mal so, der riecht krasser.
Wahnsinn ist es jetzt auch nicht.
Die meisten Gehaltsangaben bewegen sich zwischen 46k und 54k.
Also das ist jetzt nicht wirklich so dicke, was es da gibt.
Außer einer, der irgendwie von 80k verdient.
Ja. Stellanzeige gut.
Gehalt eventuell
verbesserungswürdig.
Aber da würde ich nicht so viel drauf geben.
Chat, wenn ihr hier dabei seid, euch hat die
Stellanzeige gefallen.
Hier könnt ihr euch
bewerben.
So.
Chat, die anderen
Stellenanzeigen. Die gucken
wir uns das nächste Mal an.
Ich...
Wie ging das nochmal mit dem Speichern?
Chat, konnte man
nicht die Dinger irgendwie
anklicken und...
Ah ne, das ist ein Inkognito-Tab,
oder?
Ist das ein Inkognito-Tab?
Das ist ein Inkognito-Tab, oder?
Nee, ist es nicht.
Chat, bin ich jetzt dumm?
Woran sehe ich denn, ob das ein Inkognito-Tab ist oder nicht?
Ach so, okay.
Dann steht
Inkognito oben.
Logisch, gut.
Okay, es ist kein Inkognito-Tab.
Es ist aber komisch, ich kann gar nicht mehrere
Dinge hier oben markieren.
Ich meine nicht anheften.
Ich meine alles als Lesezeichen speichern.
Alle geöffneten Tabs als...
Ach hier, Bookmark all Tabs geht da jetzt mittlerweile.
Okay.
Und wie blendet man hier jetzt die Bookmark?
Oh Gott, ich komme mir teilweise vor wie der letzte Kacknoob.
Wie blendet man hier die Bookmarks...
Die Bookmarkbar ein?
ist die bookmarks bookmarks show bookmark bar ok wir nehmen
perfekt ich brauche ich brauche einen kleinen system admin ja
Ich schaue immer auf Levels vor.
Das habe ich tatsächlich auch letztens mal im Stream angeguckt hier.
Hat er nicht Morpheus sogar mal Werbung für gemacht?
Ne, das war was anderes, ne?
Power of
Chat
Es war sehr nice, dass ihr am Start wart
Die restlichen Stellenanzeigen
Gucken wir uns wahrscheinlich im nächsten Stream an
Ich muss jetzt was futtern
Und dann hören wir uns
Beim nächsten Mal
Wenn ich irgendwas vergessen hab, Leute
Im Chat, ihr habt viel geschrieben
während ich Stellenanzeigen gelesen habe.
Wenn es etwas Wichtiges gibt, schreibt es einfach das nächste Mal
nochmal dran mit AdWoblos.
Dann werde ich mich dazu äußern.
Und meinen Senf dazugeben.
Wenn es euch gefallen hat, könnt ihr an der Stelle
ein Follow dalassen, würde mich auch freuen.
Und jetzt würde ich sagen, macht's gut.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
See you.